buitenlands
[Muziek]
[Muziek
] oke hallo en welkom iedereen
dit is actinf live stream nummer 47.0
het is 3 augustus 2022
welkom bij het actieve inferentie-
instituut
we zijn een participatief online lab en
instituut dat communiceert over leren
en oefenen toegepaste actieve inferentie
kun je  vind ons op enkele van de links op
de dia
dit is een opgenomen en gearchiveerde en
getranscribeerde en gepubliceerde live
dus geef ons alstublieft feedback
zodat we ons werk kunnen verbeteren
alle achtergronden en perspectieven zijn
welkom en we zullen de video-
etiquette live volgen  streams
alle
activiteiten van het actieve inference-instituut zijn participatief, dus laat het
ons weten als je wilt bijdragen of
meedoen ga naar
activeinference.org en klik op de links
om direct deel te nemen en om meer te weten te komen.
en uniek avontuur in 47.
we gaan
niet één paper bespreken en naast elkaar plaatsen zoals gewoonlijk,
maar hebben een benadering met meerdere ogen open
naar twee papers in deze situatie
gaan we leren en
bespreken
in een naast elkaar twee papers
actieve inferentie en ontvoering in 2021
door ati
vaiko pieteren en majid beni
ook zullen we een actieve
dynamische sociale cognitie en actieve
gevolgtrekking bespreken door ines  hippolyto en thomas
van s ook vanaf 2021
alle video's
puntjes nullen en anders zijn
inleidingen op deze ideeën en
aanvullende context geen recensie of
evaluatie of laatste woord
en we gaan
consequent hopen we deze kleuring
van een lichtrood te gebruiken voor het ontvoeringspapier
en  een lichtblauw voor de inactieven,
waardoor de ruimte open blijft voor nieuwe kleuren
en combinaties die kunnen ontstaan die enkel
gebieden van synthese demonstreren en we
gaan in dit punt nul praten met e
kele grote vragen en onze doele
bespreken en tussendoor lezen
wat een beetje anders is
dan veel livestreams,
we gaan dan
overzichtsinformatie geven over elk papier in
termen van doelen de claims de roa  dmap en
de samenvatting
gaan we dan naar een achtergrond in de
contextsectie
die veel informatie zal bevatten
over inactiviteit, semiotiek, abductieve logica
enzovoort.
We gaan dan naar een nevenschikking van
de twee artikelen
en we hebben een  veel tijd om te
discussiëren met hopelijk meerdere auteurs
in de komende
discussies.1.2 en misschien daarna, dus
vandaag wilden we een groot beeld brengen
context
praten over een aantal zeer interessante threads
bieden een beetje achtergrond die
iemand helpt deze ruimte binnen te gaan en dan te
voorzien  een eerste nevenschikking en het
doornemen van deze papieren die weer
iemand enthousiast zullen maken om de kranten te lezen
duik er dieper in en breng
hun eigen perspectief op deze
zeer interessante onderwerpen
dus
we gaan naar de inleidingen
ik ben daniel ik ben  een onderzoeker in
Californië
en ik zal meer vertellen over wat spannend is
in de komende dia's ik zal het doorgeven aan
decaan
uh goedemorgen mijn naam is decaan ik ben in
Calgary en uh ik denk dat ik
misschien was  de verwrongen geest die
probeerde dit idee samen te brengen en misschien
de manier waarop we naar actieve gevolgtrekkingen kijken een beetje te veranderen
door te proberen
twee verschillende papieren te trekken van schijnbaar
verschillende volksfocussen
en dan
beide die
ook het gebruik van actieve
gevolgtrekkingen opnemen  als een methodologie
om situationeel te analyseren en dus wat zijn
de implicaties daarvoor,
dus ik vind dat heel spannend
en ik zal het doorgeven aan stephen
dus bedankt decaan ja stephen hier ben ik
in um toronto canada um
en ik ben  echt
geïnteresseerd in beide artikelen
omdat
ze allebei veel spreken over een soort
participatieve
benaderingen in het algemeen en het idee van
hoe mensen zich in de wereld
begeven, dus de vragen rond
inactiviteit
zijn echt relevant, net als het
ontvoeringsstuk, dus
hoewel het allebei heel verschillende
kranten zijn, spreken ze allebei
heel sterk tegen me, dus dat is echt
interessant, dus ik kijk er naar uit om dat soort dingen te
kunnen
onderzoeken.  m ik werk met
uh participatieve theatergemeenschap
psychologie
gemeenschapsontwikkeling en multi-schaal
ontwikkelingsprocessen en ik ben erg
opgewonden om
te zien hoe
deze wetenschappelijke kijk
kan voldoen aan een meer
wat een praktijkgebaseerde participatieve vraag zou kunnen worden genoemd
die ik  heb er
naar gekeken, dus ik geef het terug aan
Daniel
uitstekend bedankt allebei en decaan
nogmaals bedankt voor de reis van vele maanden
de vele e-mail- en maand-
en berichtenreis die we hebben gelopen,
want ik hoop echt dat dit zich zal
ontvouwen en opnemen in  een manier
die de livestreams
en het soort materiaal waar we
doorheen werken verder brengt dan waar we zijn
geweest
en
in de
geest daarvan zal ik de decaan doorgeven
om enkele van de grote vragen hier goed te introduceren
als je er twee wilt trekken  papers die
niet veel gemeen lijken te hebben
in termen van
hun onderwerp, je
zult het vanuit een iets
andere hoek moeten bekijken in termen van niet alleen
uitzoeken wat er in een paper staat, maar
hoe die papieren kunnen worden
vergeleken, dus hebben we een aantal
vragen verzameld over het idee
van welke rol als een situationele analyse
ofwel een hulpmiddel ofwel een
realiteitsmethode actieve gevolgtrekking zou kunnen
spelen bij het
trekken van dingen die ver
weg en uit elkaar lijken te zijn en ze te verstrikken
en zo  de vragen waren in feite kan
actieve gevolgtrekking zowel
iets zijn dat iets bevat of bevat of
begrenst en ook het ding is
dat wordt begrensd of wordt gegrepen wat is actieve
gevolgtrekking of als wat als actieve nadruk
zowel het ding
dat bevat is,
zeg een partitieregel in een tabel
en  een cel
zodat de eigenlijke kloof dat we
daadwerkelijk meer informatie kunnen plaatsen in hoe
dat eruit ziet, hoe het eruit zou zien als
zowel een beperking als een scheidingsteken
tegelijk en ik denk dat het dat
wederkerigheidsstuk is dat we gaan proberen uit
te plagen  de komende
livestreams en wat is vergelijkbaar of anders
in het krijgen van grip
op modellen en een ander proces
dat modelleren is,
bedankt steven doe je wan  t om hier iets toe te voegen
nee ik denk dat
dat veel dekt het enige
dat die x die er is is een soort
aanduiding
je weet dat actieve inferentiemodellen kunnen modelleren
um frameworks dus dit dit deze
contextualisering van de term um soort
komt in  spelen, maar daar gaan we het
later over hebben, dus ja, bedankt,
geweldig en
dit is
mogelijk een van de eerste
dia's van onze doelen, omdat
het hopelijk zal helpen om
terug te komen op dit niveau.
De meme
hier vertegenwoordigt deze livestream
die samenbrengt
de twee kranten op een manier waarop we met
één hand hebben geklapt,
nu gaan we dat samenbrengen in
twee je kunt het geluid al uit
de livestream horen vooral als
je luistert
decaan wat zou je beschrijven over
rames  of hoe zou je
um samenvatten oh en nog een opmerking die ik zal
toevoegen over rna ames is dat we willen dat het
uitgebreid is, maar ook om video's te hebben
die luisterbaar zijn en van een redelijke
tijdsduur, dus er zullen veel
geschoven zijn  es die veel tekst
uit het papier hebben gekopieerd en die
alleen de video zullen pauzeren als je wilt
lezen, maar we gaan gewoon verder
met veel van de tekstdia's die we
echt wilden zeker weten dat  alle
tekst was daar onzichtbaar maar we gaan niet
alles lezen dus
alsjeblieft decaan uh vat samen over welke van deze
doelen je
wilt praten weet je ik ga het gewoon
hebben over het soort de
de wortel van elk  een van deze
kogels is een nadere blik op het
realisme instrument instrumentalisme
debat ik hoef niet in te gaan op wat dat
is als je eraan hebt deelgenomen
je weet wat we beschrijven
uh versterk een benadering met twee ogen open
waarbij het ene oog het paar actieve inferentiepapieren in zich opneemt
, de inactieve
dynamische sociale toestand
en ontvoering, terwijl het andere
oog, als het andere oog actieve gevolgtrekkingen vertoont
als een integrator van beide,
omdat we denken dat het dat werkelijk kan
doen zonder te vermengen,
het daadwerkelijk een  weven of een  vlecht
en dan is het derde punt om
de absolute noodzaak expliciet te maken als we
die eerste twee dingen gaan doen
om de temporele diepte van
modellen te begrijpen die eigenlijk
twee papers van schijnbaar verre
onderwerpen zouden bevatten als we actieve gevolgtrekkingen maken in
twee verschillende onderwerpen
en  dan hebben we gewoon
verschillende dingen eruit gehaald
die de auteurs opmerkten over
hun papieren
bedankt en stephen als je verder zou kunnen gaan
met lezen tussen die doelen door
of iets toevoegen wat je zou willen van deze
dia
ja bedankt daniel, dus
je weet er een  een stel auteurs zegt dat je
weet dat het echt naar instrumentalisme kijkt
en je weet dat je weet dat het een geldig
wetenschappelijk perspectief is, maar je weet
dat er dan een beschrijving is, je kent
deze vraag over de weg naar
um
realisme
en normalisme, zodat
je weet waar
het idee is dat in
een paper dat instrumentalisme is, is
de manier om ons in dit wetenschappelijke werk min of meer
vast te leggen of vast te
houden dat kan  worden uitgedaagd um
en we zouden manieren zien die we
misschien nodig hebben
om dat los te maken wanneer we in
participatieve benaderingen komen, dus iets
daartussenin dat die wetenschappelijke ruimte losser maakt
en een praktijkruimte is, dus
hetzelfde met het tweede punt
um
waar oke is  instrumentalisme
eh je weet de weg vooruit, dus
wat is
gedrag als je in een niche
leeft, wat zijn levende wezens
eh en hoe lossen we op
welke weg vooruit, dus als
er tegenstrijdigheden zijn,
moeten we ze met elkaar verzoenen als we in een
team zijn dat probeert  gebruik dit
um moeten we gewoon met ze leven en
gewoon verder gaan
eh of waar moeten we ze eigenlijk
markeren, dus dit is op een bepaalde manier proberen te denken
in een eh buiten misschien dit soort
laserfocus
op het wetenschappelijk
filosofische punt en oke zeggen wanneer
we proberen deze in een teamcontext te brengen,
mochten we dat willen, dan zouden we dat wat losser willen maken.
over
actieve imprints die worden voorafgegaan of
achtervoegsel je weet dat adaptieve actieve
invloed effectieve actieve invloed of
actieve inferentiemodellering
je weet hoe belangrijk het is die
verduidelijking om dan
ook na te denken over hoe het instrumentalisme
realisme stuk op deze andere manieren kan worden gebruikt,
moeten we positioneren  um
je weet volledig in de een volledig op de ander
en als we er tussenin
zitten, weet
je of er meer of minder toegang tot
kennis kan zijn op basis van de context, zo vaak in
participatief werk
verschillende soorten praktijken je weet dat
de context de sleutel is
en dan dit soort  of spreekt een
beetje over mijn eigen idee van het co-creatieve
werk en ik weet dat
je weet dat daniel heel veel met teams
en
decanen is met transformatie je
weet vaak dat er een co-creatiestuk
is er is een beetje waar je
je wilt de vlinder ondersteunen
zonder hem te verpletteren er is daar iets
heel delicaat
dus hoe kunnen we
dit soms in ruimtes brengen waar het een
c is  o-creatieve ruimte, je weet waar
modellering plaatsvindt op een subtielere
contextuele manier
en
hoewel we deze
wetenschappelijke definities en strategische
ontwerpen en harde analyses hebben
en ze nuttig zijn, willen we niet dat ze
verpletteren wat er gebeurt
en er zijn een paar  foto's daar
zeggen dat soort dingen en ik zal het
doorgeven aan decaan misschien en je kunt praten met
de bemonstering
van water ertussen en de geest de
kloof
nou ik denk dat ik denk
dat dat een mooie verklaring was en ik
denk
wanneer als en  als de auteurs kunnen
komen, zullen we er
nu wat kleur aan kunnen geven Ik denk dat
we dat hebben Ik denk dat we wat ankers in de grond hebben gezet
, maar we hebben niet gezegd
hoeveel hoeveel stroming
kan tussen die verschillende knooppunten gaan en
dat is wat ik denk dat we hier wilden
vaststellen is de tussenruimte
vaak
zoals het zegt let op de kloof dat is het
enige dat je kan doden in de
metro, goed omdat je geen aandacht besteedt
aan  de ga  p en ik denk dat de
bemonstering van de wateren ertussen
hetzelfde doet, behalve dat het een
iets ander
subtiel verschil geeft in termen van de
vloeibaarheid van dat soort gaten, dus ik
denk dat het echt interessant zou zijn
als we dat als ons portaal gebruiken  hoe
we dingen bij elkaar kunnen brengen en
ze laten
dansen terwijl ze anders
op stoelen aan de andere kant
van de kamer zouden zitten, dat zou een interessant
gesprek kunnen zijn om te beginnen met punt één en
twee,
bedankt allebei en de enige opmerking die ik zal maken
voeg hier toe is
deze discussie die we hebben gehad over de
bijvoeglijke naamwoorden die voorafgaan aan
de adaptieve affectieve etc actieve
gevolgtrekking en dan ook de focus die je hebt
gebracht naar het achtervoegsel dat x en
haakjes
actieve inferentiemodel als één instantie
of geval of realisatie
actieve gevolgtrekking hebt gebracht  raamwerk actieve
inferentieprocestheorie wat
volgt en dit doet me echt denken aan
links vertakkende en rechts vertakkende
clausules in grammatica en syntaxis
en dat er een basis c is  lause
wat is onze basisclausule en wat
vertakt zich voor, tijdens en na ik denk dat
er een zeer rijke ruimte is en ik hou echt
van deze belichaamde
en op flux gebaseerde metaforen die ons zo
goed helpen begrijpen
in de papieren overzichten dat
dit slechts enkele metadata zijn en
beschrijvingen op de papers voordat we
teruggaan naar de achtergrond in context
en dan verder gaan in de papers
die hun belangrijkste punten doornemen,
dus we gaan niet de samenvattingen lezen
ze zijn
natuurlijk allebei beschikbaar voor deze papers
hier is de samenvatting voor  actieve
inferentie en ontvoering
hier is de samenvatting voor inactieve dynamische
sociale cognitie en actieve inferentie
hier zijn de sleutelwoorden voor beide
artikelen de inactieve krant
heeft de sleutelwoorden sociale cognitie nicheconstructie
actieve inferentietheorie van geest en
activisme en dynamische systeemtheorie
de ontvoeringspapier heeft de  trefwoorden
ontvoering actieve gevolgtrekking vrije energie
principe eerst en algemene
triadische relaties en doorboren
laten we naar de doelen van
en de beweringen van
het ontvoeringspapier gaan,
dus
decaan zou je
een van de doelen van het ontvoeringspapier willen dekken
wat ik zou willen doen is gewoon een soort van
voorspellen wat
beide papieren willen nastreven en
dat  is dat je een sleutelwoord zult zien in de
tweede kogel van deze, dat is
alliantie en dan zijn er woorden die
je in de andere krant zult zien,
waar ze opnieuw zeggen dat
we willen dat dingen samenkomen,
maar we willen  wees voorzichtig met hoe
we dat samenkomen beschrijven, we willen niet
dat het metaforisch wordt opgevat
als een vermenging als een ongedaan maken van
twee twee of meer dingen waarvan we denken dat
ze een associatieve
um-relatie hebben en dus denk ik dat wanneer
je door de  doelen van de twee
papers als je een beetje een stap terug doet,
zul je zien dat de auteurs
van beide
papers een harde ex-uitleg doen over aan welke
relatie
ze willen dat we aandacht besteden aan en dus
dat is iets dat ze allebei  kranten
delen het is een zware nadruk  ass op
relatie
geweldig punt en ze zijn allebei zeer
rijk en krachtig geschreven
en hier zien we alliantie en trouw
en er zal zeker
veel discussie zijn in beide artikelen over het
integreren van ongelijksoortige of gedeeltelijk
gerelateerde ontologieën en vocabulaire sets
en verschillende denkers verschillende threads
van intellectuele ontwikkeling kunnen
deze citaten uit de paper worden gelezen
en worden natuurlijk uitgebreid in de
paper,
maar zoals decaan al zei, ligt de focus van deze paper
op de intellectuele alliantie
tussen actieve inferentie en vrije-energieprincipe
fep en in de eerste plaats het werk van
cs pierce
in termen van  semiotiek pragmatiek
grammatica abductieve logica dat is het
doel synthese is het samenbrengen van die
twee op een manier die synergetisch
is en betekenis geeft stephen
ja en gewoon in vervolg op wat
je zegt de beide documenten en
vooral de abductieve
het geeft een manier  om te kijken naar
gebieden die echt moeilijk te
simuleren zijn voor computers um en
de manier waarop ontvoering plaatsvindt, of in het
bijzonder met mensen, is
zeer geavanceerd en ik denk
dat het erg nuttig is om vervolgens semiotiek te zien
die eigenlijk veel wordt gebruikt
in
theater-echografie en decorontwerp en
pragmatisme, dus hierin gebracht
met een met een echt
een theorie  dat is dat je weet dat de
wetenschap overstijgt vaak juist wordt vaak gebruikt op
andere gebieden, zoals
de natuurwetenschappen heeft er enig nut voor,
maar het wordt vaak gebruikt in de geesteswetenschappen, dus
ik denk dat
dit tegen dat stuk spreekt over
wat er
wordt onthuld dat soort geheime saus
dat soort treffer in de ziel dat
normaal gesproken ontbreekt en in actie is
er ook iets dat lijkt op die
geweldige
beweringen van de krant
die overal in de krant staan, maar
om enkele van de belangrijkste beweringen te benadrukken,
beweren ze dat dat doel dat ze hadden nagestreefd
maken
tussen het werk van actieve gevolgtrekking en
het ontvoerings- en semiotisch
perspectief, beweren ze dat dat
haalbaar is en bieden ze een
eerste  schets ervoor
in deze theoretische theoretische
integratie
van het nieuwe en het oude
iets rood iets blauws iets
nieuws iets ouds
en de twee kaders het nieuwe en het
oude respectievelijk
zijn de moderne concretiseringen van
neurowetenschap en cognitieve wetenschap
vertegenwoordigd door een principe van vrije energie
en op de  oud een historisch nauwkeurige
en nauwkeurige interpretatie van
ontvoeringsinferentie inclusief het belang van
de economie van onderzoek alle dingen waar
we op terug zullen komen wilde alleen
de beweringen daar verduidelijken kan ik er gewoon een
toevoegen ja alsjeblieft heel
snel dus theoretische integratie
daar ik  bedoel van wat als je terug kunt
denken aan toen we het hadden over onze
doelen,
nu is de vraag dit is wat de
auteurs zeggen
wat we ons afvragen is dat maakt
actieve gevolgtrekking zowel het
integratieproduct als de integrator het proces
en nogmaals i  ik wil
die ene stap een beetje plagen omdat ik denk
dat dat weer gaat gebeuren als we
kijken  op het andere papier
zullen ze een andere nomenclatuur gebruiken, maar
ze gaan hetzelfde zeggen en
nogmaals
, het is moeilijk om de overeenkomsten te zien,
tenzij jij en jij ze niet hoeven te verzinnen
, je
moet ze gewoon
opmerken in
de  twee verschillende soorten bossen
en een punt dat ze
allebei in zekere zin actieve gevolgtrekking gebruiken als
een integrator en een
differentiator we maken een
geïntegreerd model van interne en
externe en algemene toestanden
door ze te differentiëren en dan
natuurlijk integratie  en differentiatie hebben
ook een gezamenlijk
gebruik in de wiskunde met de integrale
en de afgeleide notatie, dus er
zullen veel dingen bij elkaar komen.
neurowetenschap in deze computationele
neurowetenschap en om dat te benadrukken
omdat ik denk dat
iets de realiteit is in de wereld daarbuiten
de cultuur daar
waar deze ideeën zijn  er circuleert
dat
neurowetenschap op zijn kop wordt gezet door
actieve invloed
neurowetenschap als een veld
zoals mensen begrijpen dat het
een soort
deductief
proces is van dingen die binnenkomen en vervolgens
worden geëvalueerd en
geconcretiseerd in tegenstelling tot deze
voorspellende reis, dus ik denk dat het
echt heel nuttig is
want dit is iets waar
we allemaal mee te maken hebben en ik denk dat wat ik ook heb
opgemerkt toen ik met sommige neurowetenschappers sprak,
is dat ze
een existentiële crisis hebben gehad en
deels vaak zijn verschoven door met inactieve
claims te komen en echt te zien of  inactieve
beweringen zijn er hoe kan hun werk met
neurowetenschap
zo bij elkaar worden gehouden, dus
er is dit er is hier een
stuk dat betrekking heeft op het algemene en
dat dat algemene
stuk is belangrijker
wanneer we actieve invloed beginnen uit te brengen vanuit
de specialistische gebieden  waar het een soort
enclave is en de spelregels
bekend zijn en je in de gebieden bent waar
mensen neurowetenschap goed zeggen  ik weet wat
dat betekent
en ga je gang, dus bedankt, bedankt,
het artikel heeft relatief weinig secties
het heeft een inleiding
het presenteert dan een
paar actieve gevolgtrekkingen in het licht van
ontvoering
ontvoering in het licht van actieve
gevolgtrekking
enigszins schuine verwijzing naar niets in
biologie heeft zin behalve in het licht
van evolutie of behalve in het licht van
iets en dit zijn twee lichten
terug naar die eilanden wat is de ruimte
ertussen
en dan is er een discussie
over de economie van onderzoek en de
naturalisatie van vrije energie en de conclusie
en de  konijnenholen doorboren diep
gaan we gaan er binnenkort op een paar ingaan
op de inactieve papieren
dus hier gaan we de
ames-claims en de routekaart beschrijven van de inactieve
dynamische sociale cognitie en actieve
inferentiepapier
de krant presenteert een twee-  fold doel
om nieuwe accounts te ontleden
die activisme vermengen met inferentiële
accounts en uit te leggen waarom
daarbij tegenstrijdigheid
is het eerste doel
en de se  Het doel is om
de enige redelijke accountkoppeling in
activisme en inferentiële accounts aan te bieden,
vooral in dit geval van sociale
cognitie,
dus
ja alsjeblieft niet raad eens wat ik hoopte
zou je nu het woord linking
paars voor ons kunnen veranderen
ja
bedankt
we hebben verschillende manieren om  het beschrijven van de
tussen die Stephen deed het prachtig
om te benadrukken voordat we echt
naar de um de kranten zelf begonnen te kijken
ja het zit er tussenin ja
het is geweldig en het is eigenlijk
door jouw verzoek en het
diaplatform wordt het een actieve dynamische
sociale stigmatisering
en zo
dat is een proof of concept voor wat,
maar dit is het doel van dit artikel oke
ze hebben ook veel claims
die tijdens de discussie worden verwoord
en ze gebruiken zelfs een zeer duidelijke
notatie om de specifieke claims
van ander werk en van hun eigen werk te beschrijven
en over welke claims  en hypothesen
hebben welke logische relatie
ze gaan beweren over de
aard van cognitie en zijn  belichaamde
basis
zullen ze enkele van
de beweringen bespreken die verband houden met de menselijke sociaal-
cognitieve niche
en praten over het belang van de
opbouw van een niche voor relatie-enculturatie
en dan gaan ze praten
over de theory of mind Tom
en over de compatibiliteit of
tegenstrijdigheden
geassocieerd met het koppelen van
inactieve
beweringen met
theory of mind of inferentiële accounts
de
roadmap van het artikel legt veel van deze doelen en
claims heel duidelijk uit ze beginnen met een
inleiding
en introduceren een
recent, maar invloedrijk werk op het gebied van
actieve inferentie, namelijk het kader van
denken door andere geesten
ttom
en zij, zoals ze zeggen, ontleden dit
verslag
om te proberen uit elkaar te halen hoe in
hun ogen
de inactieve en de inferentiële tellingen
bij elkaar werden gebracht,
ze hebben ook een figuur die een
Markov-deken beschrijft, wat een
concept zal zijn dat in beide  van
hun papieren
sectie 2 moet iets
afwijzende inactieve gevolgtrekking geven t  via
andere geesten
gaan ze twee veronderstellingen gebruiken,
namelijk dat sociale cognitie reduceert tot
mentale representatie en twee dat
sociale cognitie vanaf de geboorte vast zit
en dat ze het niet eens zijn met
beide veronderstellingen en in hun
verzet tegen deze veronderstellingen
ondersteund door subclaims  en bewijs
dat hen tot hun bredere conclusies zal leiden,
gaan ze dynamische
systeemtheorie gebruiken
en praten over hoe dst
kan worden gekoppeld aan een activisme in termen
van compatibiliteit en wat deze twee
kaders elkaar bieden binnen een
instrumentalistische lezing
en  dan gaan ze het hebben over actieve
inferentie specifiek in de context van
dynamische systeemtheorie enerzijds en
inactieve
cognitie sociale cognitie
anderzijds dat is de inactieve dynamische
woordafbreking die
ze zullen beschrijven met een paar cijfers
over overeenkomsten en verschillen
tussen sociale inactiviteit in het algemeen  zoals
geconceptualiseerd buiten actieve
gevolgtrekking en dan zijn ze...  gaan
visueel introduceren hoe actieve gevolgtrekking
dat beeld verrijkt
en dan hebben ze een zeer interessante
tabel die onderscheid maakt tussen of tussen
fenomenen die in de natuurlijke wereld worden
waargenomen en waargenomen gedrag in de natuurlijke
wereld.
achtergrond in
contextsectie dus in dit gedeelte van de punt
nul
gaan we
zeker enkele citaten uit de krant gebruiken,
maar we gaan ook een stap terug doen
en slechts het topje van de
ijsberg van de beurs en het
onderzoek demonstreren  die we hebben uitgevoerd in de aanloop
naar dit punt,
hopelijk om
de luisteraar of lezer te prikkelen
en om wat context te bieden in deze
zeer diepe discussies die
in de kranten zullen worden benaderd en benaderd.
Ik zal hier een eerste opmerking geven of decaan
, ga alsjeblieft voor  het is
gewoon, ik denk dat ik denk dat dit een
spectaculair moment is om te zeggen
oké, dus
achtergrond en context, dus we hebben het
misschien over
de tijdelijke en de fysieke
setting,
dus tha  Het is nu iets dat we
situationeel kunnen analyseren
en nogmaals,
het maakt niet uit of je actieve
gevolgtrekking gebruikt of dat je een cast-
model gebruikt of dat je
professionele initiatieven
gebruikt. Het komt erop neer dat iedereen probeert te
achterhalen
wat de situatie is
door middel van een analyse  methode en en en
ik kan me voorstellen dat elk van die
methoden meer of minder levensvatbaar is,
afhankelijk van wat de situatie zowel
tijdelijk als fysiek is,
dus ik denk
dat dat de kritieke dingen zijn we
zeggen niet dat elk van deze
papieren goed of slecht is
we zeggen dat elk van deze
artikelen een focus heeft op een andere
achtergrond-contextcombinatie,
minimaal twee, dus als we nu de twee dingen
samenvoegen, kunnen we niet zeggen
dat het hetzelfde zal
zijn dat we gaan doen  kom met
dat onze doelen als mensen die nu
naar de twee papieren naast elkaar hebben gekeken
die een geheel nieuwe entiteit gaan creëren
bedankt
om deze achtergrond en context te leiden
tualizing sectie ik wilde
een van mijn favoriete ambachtelijke dichters aanroepen
william blake
en blake schreef
tegengestelden zijn positief een ontkenning is
geen
tegendeel ontkenningen zijn niet tegengesteld tegengestelden
bestaan wederzijds maar
ntkenningen bestaan geen uitzonderin
en en bezwaren en ongeloof bestaan nie
en zullen nooit worden georganise
rd  voor altijd en eeuwig
einde quote
contrairs in dit blakeyan
viervoudige logische raamwerk maken
in
feite deel uit van een dialectiek en ze bestaan
n functie van elkaar zoals convex en co
caaf of als zwaartekracht en stral
ng zoals Buckminster Fuller het zou kunnen breng
n en du
ontkenningen in deze poëtische  kader
zijn diegene die
niet bestaan,
terwijl a en b integendeel kunnen zijn,
terwijl a en niet a een verschillende
logische relatie hebben en dit soort
viervoudige logische benadering
voor het herkennen van de toestandsruimte en de
waarheidsclaims die meerdere naast elkaar staande
beweringen kunnen hebben met
onder elkaar
komt ook voor in veel wereldkennistradities
um fo  r voorbeeld de kata scotty
en dit is een logische
tool en methode die
al heel lang wordt toegepast in de uh de dharmische
tradities van de Indiase context
wilden dat bieden en ook um
met deze afbeeldingen die een van
jullie welkom is om te onderzoeken
wat  heeft een hand klappen of een persoon
die de splitsingen doet
te maken met tegenspraak en
ontkenning
ja decaan ja ook met
betrekking tot tegenspraak en ik
denk dat dit
wijst op
het soort contextuele stuk
um
het situationele
uh-analysestuk
is
dat er een situatie
is waarin
er zijn
tegenstellingen die worden geconstrueerd als dat
logisch is
en dat is ook belichaamd en uitgevoerd
door ons leven, dus het zou heel goed kunnen zijn
als een baby we weten
de morfologie van het kind in
verschillende
stadia in verschillende contexten geeft de
manieren
om situationele vast te stellen
bewustzijn
en de tegenstrijdigheden daarin
als dingen gecodificeerd worden, dus je hebt
deze
deze situationele
um
processen zijn een soort van eh zijn wat we aan het
doen zijn in deze voortdurende modelleringsstroom
het soort praktijkgebieden
in deze verschillende artikelen die ze
ondersteunen de inactivist voelt een praktijk of
de eh meer computationele
praktijkgebieden ze zijn  wat we
belichamen en waar we aan beginnen en we leren
en dat is wat we een soort van
intuïtief modelleren op een manier die we een
gevoel krijgen voor hoe we moeten modelleren
in deze situaties de tegenstrijdigheden
maar dat modelleren
vaak en dit is het gevaar
wanneer  het wordt
overmeesterd door iemand met hun model,
d.w.z.
iemand is in hun wereld aan het modelleren hoe
het is om zichzelf te zijn of probeert het te
verwerken ze gaan naar een counselor
met hun model en dat model
wordt gebruikt om hen aan het model te passen
en dan die counselor  zal ons vertellen
wat hun probleem is hoe het is ingelijst, dus
ik denk dat dit modelmodel in
um
hier heel relevant is, omdat je weet dat
als deze tegenstrijdigheden eenmaal zijn
vastgesteld, het heel goed kan zijn dat
er een probleem is  del gemaakt binnen dat
domein
en dan kan iemand die niet noodzakelijk
in dat domein
is,
worden toegeschreven aan het model, ze weten niet
wat het spel is, ze zijn niet in het
proces en het model neemt het over, dus dat
soort schakelt over naar de splitsingen
want dan oke we hebben twee dingen
ze zijn samen
we hebben het hier over ja laten we
je openstellen en je hebt een standpunt
oke dus ik ben een beetje en op een gegeven moment
is het alsof dat geen standpunt is broer
dat is  dat is een splitsing die je daar hebt gekregen
, je zult voorzichtig moeten zijn
, dus je bent op het idee gekomen dat
je dingen nu opent, waar ze
één ding waren om mee te beginnen als ze een
standpunt waren dat ze werden vastgehouden  in sommige opzichten
zijn ze op een bepaalde manier gesplitst op een manier waarop
ze nu
van elkaar zijn geïsoleerd, weet je, ik
veronderstel dat we hopelijk een manier proberen te vinden
om ze niet in een te duwen,
noch door uit elkaar te gaan, misschien een
standpunt daartussenin
hebben  is op de een of andere manier behendig en
heeft in dit geval betrekking op realisme en
ins  trumentalisme dat een soort echo is van een aantal
bredere thema's
bedankt decaan heel
snel eh veel mensen hebben
het yogi-baronisme gehoord van wanneer je
een splitsing in de weg ziet
nemen en ik weet dat met
veel van de term joint
is gekomen  veel gezamenlijke waarschijnlijkheid
bijvoorbeeld en dus het idee van een splitsing hier
is echt een goed idee voor metaforisch
gesproken, want
als je
naar iets kijkt met actieve
interferentie en je gaat ervan uit dat je
in een theelabyrint-experiment goed naar
links of rechts moet gaan  mensen
kunnen een splitsing in de weg zien en nemen
dat is een soort staande grap
als je een vork in mijn benen ziet neem ze, je
hoeft niet per se
een orbee te kiezen je kunt
het hele ding nemen en ik denk dat dat is wat
blake  probeert te wijzen met deze
oefening en dat is dus een contradictie
nee als ik gereedschap op de weg zie kan
ik het aan maar als ik niet open sta
voor het idee dat vork niet alleen
links of rechts betekent,
dan ben ik  al zelfbeperkt in termen
van wat  ik ben aan het testen wat ik
situationeel analyseer,
bedankt allebei voor de meer
directe trefwoorden,
dus in actie van de
site thisdefinitions.net een actie is een van de mogelijke
manieren om kennis te organiseren en de
vormen van interactie met de wereld
inactieve kennis  is kennis die tot stand
komt door actie en is gebaseerd
op motorische vaardigheden zoals het manipuleren van
objecten fietsen of
sporten dat is slechts een van de vele
definities die zijn gegeven
we hebben ook verschillende livestreams en
papieren discussies gehad over een actie in actieve
gevolgtrekking
bijvoorbeeld
in actieve livestream nummer zes lang
geleden toen we in 2020 ramstead bespraken
een verhaal van twee dichtheden
actieve gevolgtrekking is een actieve gevolgtrekking
in
2021 bespraken we ook een paper van
hippolyto helemaal belichaamde bekwame
prestaties waar de actie is
en interessant
voor  op de een of andere manier deze
discussie hier is een dia van
die livestream um
met uh van de hippolyto-krant
en  hier hadden we de doordringende
uh triade en we hadden de symboliek en
dit de semiotiek en de verwijzingen naar het
frans,
dus we hadden het eigenlijk over het
zeer verwante concept van representatie
en
inderdaad degenen die de  boven
de discussie rond
inactivisme en het
inferentiële account zal sterk afhangen van de
kwestie van representatie en cognitieve
representaties wat die zijn waar of
of ze bestaan enzovoort um da
was livestream 23. ook v
n dit artikel van sangati helemaal uh ze
lay out gewoon visueel we
gaan binnenkort meer voorstellingen zien
in hun ogen
enkele van de verschillen tussen
traditionele sociale cognitie
en inactieve sociale cognitie
en dus in plaats van alleen een visuele
interpretatie van de naam van de afbeelding
zou je het willen geven
nee ik wacht op  jij naar beneden in de volgende oke
dus hier wat ik zie is dat in de
traditionele sociaal-cognitieve inferentiële
rekeningen
de versnellingen  draaien in de hersenen
en dan zijn er perceptie actie loops
en koppelingen die sociale
entiteiten in hun lichaam verbinden, maar het
lichaam wordt gezien als een interface
voor dat soort informatieoverdracht
een extreme houding of eenvoudige visuele
representatie
en dan hier in contrast we  zie dat
de tandwielen overal zijn, ook in
de omgeving in de nis in de
ruimte ertussen
en dat ja, de hersenen doen dingen,
maar het maakt ook deel uit van een ingevoerd systeem
dat dit ingecultiveerde
sociaal-cognitieve proces een beetje
meer implementeert in een holistisch kader, dus  decaan ja
ja, ik wilde net
zeggen dat we zo dadelijk gaan kijken waar
het ontvoeringsgedoe over gaat, maar voor
nu
zou ik willen dat mensen
het idee in hun hoofd houden dat
dit spreekt tot een soort van  temporele
diepte, maar die temporele diepte is
verticaal.
Ik denk dat ontvoering, kijkend naar langere
tijdlijnen gedurende honderden jaren, meer
horizontaal is, dus houd er rekening mee dat
we lang zijn  koning temporele diepte maar de
focus ligt op een verticale of een diepe
temporele diepte in plaats van een brede laterale
temporele diepte
ze zijn allebei van belang, maar ze zijn orthogonaal
betekent niet dat ze in conflict zijn
met elkaar het betekent alleen dat ze
gaan  in verschillende richtingen dat is alles wat
ik wil zeggen dat
het grappig is links en rechts of west en
oost dat zijn tegengestelde richtingen maar
het zijn geen ontkennende richtingen en
dus daar beginnen we te
zien hoe orthogonaliteit of schaarste
of voorwaardelijke onafhankelijkheid
verleend wordt  door een markov-deken bijvoorbeeld
hoe die kunnen worden gezien in het kader
van tegenstellingen maar niet ontkenningen
stephen
en die versnelling in het diagram in de rechterhand
daar de versnelling ertussen
weet je die tijdelijke
diepte kan hebben die dit lichaam van geest kan hebben
omgevingsstuk is er zeker zoals je
zegt en maakt duidelijk als een
analyse-eenheid die echt een uitdaging is en ik
zou daar ook als versnellingswoorden
woorden zijn
twitch
t  heksen van onze stembox geeft ons
woorden in de ruimte om ons heen,
dus je weet dat ze ook als gereedschap worden gebruikt,
dus plotseling zijn
we veel meer verstrikt, zelfs als het
alleen maar spraak is,
ja en het kost tijd voor de spraak
om door de  internet en door
ruimte en tijd
een beetje meer diepgang over sociale
inactiviteit
deze uh inactie onderzoeksbron
beschrijft verschillende betekenissen en zintuigen van
inactiviteit
in de performatieve en de
voortbrengende zintuigen dus lees alstublieft
en ook een heel mooi artikel uit 2009 in
cognitieve semiotiek door de bruyne  en de
Haan
bespreken enkele van de relaties van een
activisme in sociale cognitie
en ze hebben uitstekend werk geleverd door
samen te vatten wat de inferentiële
en de inactivistische accounts kunnen
samenbrengen en een soort van
discussie over die koppeling ja alsjeblieft decaan
ja ik
heb die mensen gelezen omdat ik het heb gevonden  en
hier is iets interessants als ze een
brugmetafoor gaan gebruiken.
Ik denk dat een activisme wel een brug heeft,
het is gewoon een verticale brug,
het is de  kant van een gebouw gaat omhoog
en dus
um
niets, niet om niet te bekritiseren wat
ze hier hebben geschreven, maar ik denk dat
er een schuld is
en er is een mogelijkheid om te overspannen het is
alleen dat het
verticaal gaat het gaat niet traditioneel van
links naar rechts
geweldig
dus  verder met een beetje diepgang in
ontvoering en semiotiek.
Nou,
we hadden samen een behoorlijk leertraject
en het
ontvoeringsdocument
met
een of anderhalf of zelfs twee van de
auteurs die echte experts waren,
leverde veel details op
doordring was een productief schrijver en denker
en medewerker en ook veel van het
werk was niet gepubliceerd, wat betekent dat
er enkele mysterieuze referentiesystemen zijn
en niet alles is
hypertoegankelijk.
je wilt
alles op deze pagina samenvatten
niets anders dan als je
als je geïnteresseerd bent in
pragmatisme en je voorbij
william james wilt komen eigenlijk william  james en
charles sanders pierce had een beetje een
ze waren ze waren misschien 150 jaar geleden
de eerste
conflicten over hoe dingen werken
eh het is eigenlijk echt het is een geweldig
startpunt in termen van hoe mensen die
in competitie lijken te zijn met
elkaar eigenlijk maken  elkaar
slimmer, maar in feite veel van de
dingen veel van de ideeën waar we 150 jaar
later nu op terugkijken we zouden
moeten zeggen dat ze misschien het gevoel hadden dat ze
met elkaar concurreerden, maar ik denk dat
wat ze deden was doorgeven  of
op de een of andere manier een beter model aan
het bouwen waren omdat ze niet altijd naar de dingen keken,
ze hadden beide ogen
open dus dat wil ik maar zeggen ga naar
de algemene site het is echt goed
ja het is geweldig deze representatie
ironisch genoeg de
juiste slash  is van het bekende
peerson triade semiotisch raamwerk waar een
stopteken het representamen wordt genoemd de vertegenwoordigde
instantie het fysieke stopteken het echte
stopteken
het object is de puinhoop  leeftijdsauto's moeten
hier stoppen en de interpretant is dat ik hier moet
stoppen en dat is waar we dat entiteitsbureau krijgen
Ik vond een interessant artikel
over de gebruikersinterface
dat enkele van deze echt
tijdloze discussies over semiotiek en
logica in een digitale context brengt die
ze toepassen  die halvering van de
gebruikersinterface-metafoor die
je je kunt voorstellen als dat een
stopteken in de echte wereld was of als het een
knop op een website in een gebruikersinterfacecontext was
en
iedereen kan pauzeren en enkele van
deze uitstekende selecties uit citaten lezen
en uh
lezingen gegeven
over hoe
kopieën tekens en symbolen met elkaar verbonden zijn
door logica en semiosis
hier veel, maar we zullen
specifiek doorgaan met ontvoering dus dit was een
beetje op pierce en de definitie
van semiotiek in tegenstelling tot
de wetenschap van de dingen de meer positieve
wetenschappen  en de wetenschap van vormen
die de meer formele wetenschappen zijn
wat is ontvoering redeneren
dit was erg fascinerend om te onderzoeken
dit is een citaat uit de ontvoering  In een artikel dat
ze schreven is het gebruikelijk in de secundaire
literatuur,
bijv. dat voortbouwen op doorboren
om ontvoering in
twee delen of twee soorten te zien plaatsvinden
generatieve ontvoering en selectieve
ontvoering
hier is een ander perspectief op de twee
typen of de twee variëteiten of twee
componenten tweetaktmotor  van
ontvoering uit de Stanford encyclopedie
uh filosofie die
ze in de filosofische
literatuur schreven de term ontvoering wordt gebruikt in
twee verwante maar verschillende betekenissen
in beide betekenissen de term verwijst naar
verklarend redeneren
in de historisch eerste betekenis het
verwijst
naar de plaats van verklarend redeneren bij het
genereren van hypothesen  dat is generatieve
ontvoering, terwijl het in de tweede betekenis
, de betekenis die het meest wordt
gebruikt in de moderne literatuur,
verwijst naar de plaats van verklarend
redeneren bij het rechtvaardigen of evalueren van een
opgesomde reeks hypothesen
en in zekere zin maakt het
de inhoud zinvol  moet worden gegenereerd om
te worden samengesteld, de ideeën moeten specifiek zijn  ie
opgesomd om te worden gerechtvaardigd of
geëvalueerd
decaan ga hier alsjeblieft verder op,
gewoon heel snel, dus
we hebben nu rood en blauw, wat
echt heel belangrijk was om te benadrukken
dat je beide nodig hebt, je hebt er minimaal
twee nodig om de uitleg naast abductief te laten
verschijnen
redeneren in de
probabilistische zin is ook bekend als
gevolgtrekking naar de beste verklaring is een
vorm van logisch redeneren die kijkt naar
de meest waarschijnlijke hypothese om iets te verklaren
een voorbeeld kwamen de witte bonen
in de linkerhand uit de zak met
voorwerpen in de rechter  hand hier kunnen
we zien hoe de naar voren gebrachte hypothese
afhangt van
een onvolledige waarneming of een
gevolgtrekking zijn er ook bonen in de
zak en zelfs als dat zo is, is dat de bron
voor wat is overgedragen aan de
linkerhand dus weer temporele diepte
wanneer je aankomt in  een situatie
wat voor soort achtergrond en wat voor
soort context heb je
gaat naar deze deze vierde vorm
van logica die of portemonnee er letterlijk uitziet  Je hebt je
hele leven
geprobeerd om het
uit elkaar te halen en vervolgens te
hervormen tot een soort samenhang
en
degenen die meeluisteren, kunnen
vermoedens van eerdere zintuiglijke waarnemingen beginnen te
actualiseren van opvattingen over de
wereld, zelfs actieselectie die in het
spel komt, vooral vertaling van de mogelijkheden
onmiddellijke
actiebeschikbaarheid in  beleid dat kan
worden geëvalueerd door hun verwachte vrije
energie, maar we komen er wel.
Laten we het hebben
over ontvoering en hier zijn enkele van de
zeer fascinerende artikelen die beschikbaar zijn over
commons met betrekking tot ontvoering veel daar
en om verder te gaan met een van
de  bronnen van commons over
ontvoering als praktische gevolgtrekking
door thomas capitan
dit werk,
waar we niet alles over gaan lezen,
gaat in op veel interessante
punten
over die dubbele aard van ontvoering
met het genereren van hypothesen
en het selecteren van hypothesen
en onderscheidt dat hypotheseselectie
deductief kan maken  geldige evaluaties,
maar de creativiteitsfase  e is
niet-inferentieel en heeft veel
resonantie met niet-pre-censurerende
ideeën en het hebben van een inclusieve
discussie bij het brainstormen
en erkennen dat er een
waan moet zijn in een eindige periode van ruimte
en tijd
bovendien is er enige discussie
hier
dit was
relateren
terwijl we teruggaan naar of verweven zijn
met het vrije-energieprincipe
aanvankelijk bewustzijn van de hypothese
komt met de observatie van een
samengevoegd geheel door middel van een
ongecontroleerd inzicht in de wereld van
ideeën in wat hij derdeheid noemde zoals
gegeven in perceptie
het nieuwe bedenken van enige  voorbeeld van
premisse 2
die een eerder deel van het papier citeert, wordt
veroorzaakt door eerdere cognities
priors
de inhoud ervan wordt gesuggereerd door de feiten
observaties zintuiglijke waarnemingen
maar niet alles wat wordt gesuggereerd wordt afgeleid
uit de cognitie van de feiten
en zo
gaat pierce verder met te beschrijven dat er
operaties zijn van de  geest die
logisch precies analoog zijn aan
gevolgtrekkingen,
alleen accepterend dat ze niet zijn  bewust
en daarom oncontroleerbaar en
daarom niet onderhevig aan kritiek, dus
vragen buiten beschouwing latend als of
onbewuste processen
als controleerbaar kunnen worden beschouwd,
zien we hints van
perceptie als onbewuste gevolgtrekkingen en
we zien ook continuïteit
tussen processen van aandacht en
bewustzijn
bewuste gevolgtrekkingen
en andere onbewuste gevolgtrekkingen  en dus biedt dit
in zekere zin ook een
geïntegreerd raamwerk van perceptie
leren geloof actualiseren temporele diepte
bewust en onbewust bewustzijn
al deze kenmerken worden onderzocht in het
Perzische werk en het
ontvoeringsdocument zal dat feit heel specifiek
benadrukken
oke een beetje doorgaan  beetje meer
eh ontvoering en retroductie
zou je hier iets aan willen toevoegen
decaan
nou ik bedoel mensen die het hebben bestudeerd en
geanalyseerd dit
wonder soms of dit
een
morfologie was of dat we
de twee termen tegelijkertijd of weer
onderling uitwisselbaar kunnen gebruiken
het is er waarschijnlijk een  van die dingen
waar als je
wilt weten wat de details zijn,
je waarschijnlijk een kijkje moet nemen
omdat het interessant is, maar het is
op dit moment niet het enige wat we eigenlijk willen
doen is
hier, ik zal deze
retroductie van de  proces waarbij we uit
de verrassende reeks feiten
naar een
vermoeden worden geleid we hebben vermoedens veel
theorie gebruikt om ze te
verklaren veel logici weigeren deze laatste gevolgtrekking te noemen
omdat de conclusie zo extreem
problematisch is dat het iets meer is
dan een ondervraging
ik weet zeker dat ze het bij het verkeerde eind
hebben, maar ze hebben niet
de echte wetenschappelijke
definitie van gevolgtrekking in handen, dus wat hij
hier eigenlijk zegt, is laten we geen
abductief redeneren infrarood of
inductief redeneren
de logische rechtvaardiging van een
retroductie noemen, waarvan de juiste
conclusie is dat de  vermoede stand
van zaken is waarschijnlijk
in de vage zin van de neiging
om te lijken op de werkelijke
stand van zaken en dit is het deel
waar zo wh  bij vervangt dat
instrumentalisme
wat we ook definiëren als
dit is weer
dit is een van die raadsels als het
niet is als het geen
echte
staat is is het wat niet dan wat een
onwerkelijke of een niet-echte staat is omdat het daar is
dat
we hebben  noemde het
wat wat vult dat wat voelt dat
uiteindelijk om het geheel te maken dat is de
vraag hier
en ook opnieuw de moeite waard om wat
van het eerdere werk van een van de auteurs
van de ontvoeringspaper te lezen en men kan
in hun onderzoek een sterke lijn van
ontwikkeling en
veel van het werk uitbreiden en moderniseren
laten we gewoon
ja, dus ik heb die uh berenborden neergezet
omdat ik een heel heel heel snel verhaal wil vertellen,
dus als je ergens woont waar
beren zijn als het berenbord blijft staan
, beginnen mensen de  echt
tekenobject
en ze worden niet langer tolken
, ze
verliezen opzettelijk die triadisch, dus
als je bezig bent met
dierenwelzijn en je niet wilt dat beren
te gewend raken
aan hu  man contact je moet
erg selectief zijn wanneer je het bord plaatst
en vooral wanneer je het bord verwijdert,
dus ik wilde dat daar plaatsen, want
dat is een groot deel van het ontvoerings- en
retroductiestuk,
je moet soms dingen wegnemen
voor  ontvoering om te werken het is het verwijderen
van mogelijkheden
die eigenlijk
de nadruk legt
ik denk dat we gewoon doorgaan met realisme
en instrumentalisme omdat we
in de daaropvolgende discussies meer terug zullen komen op ontvoering,
dus
hier zijn enkele citaten uit een eerlijk stuk
papier
volgens het realisme is dergelijke kennis
feitelijke kennis beschrijvend voor
algemene of bijzondere kenmerken van het
universum, dus dat betekent niet dat
het zwaartekrachtmodel zwaartekracht is, dat betekent niet
dat het zwaartekrachtmodel is wat de
objecten van de zwaartekracht zijn,
maar een realist zou  merk op dat
bijvoorbeeld formele modellen van zwaartekracht
ons leren over het bestaan van objec
en waarop de zwaar
ekracht werkt en de beschrijving van een kracht vrijgeven die k
n  niet direct gezien worden gehoord of
gevoeld maar toch merkbare
invloed hebben
krachten zijn echte dingen zijn echt
volgens het instrumentalisme
zelfs een theorie die helemaal correct
is beschrijft niets maar dient als
een instrument voor de voorspelling van de
feiten die de empirische
inhoud ervan vormen
en dus  nogmaals op het zwaartekrachtvoorbeeld van dit newton
zouden de instrumentalisten het standpunt kunnen innemen dat er geen
entiteiten zijn
zwaartekracht en zwaartekrachtvelden
zijn slechts instrumentele toepassingen
van statistische
argumenten of mogelijk zelfs sociale
of machtsdynamische argumenten
en een instrumentalist kan het
bestaan van objecten, entit
iten en krachten in dit ontkennen  case
en zelfs dingen tot het niveau
van scepsis hebben rond woorden als
instrumenten en de relaties rond
communicatie
en hoe het zintuiglijke gegevens ordent en voorspelt
we hebben realisme en
instrumentalisme vrij veel onderzocht in de
streams en we hebben veel benadrukt in het
werk van Mel Andrew  in livestreamnummer  14. nog
een dia over realisme en
instrumentalisme en dan
voel je alsjeblieft vrij,
ik zal een aantal van de onderste nog
eens beschrijven. Het onderscheid op de kaart is de
sleutel tot het gesprek over realisme en instrumentalisme.
Er is ook een verscheidenheid aan uitstekend
filosofisch werk
voor geweest  voorbeeld een opvolger van het realisme
anti-realisme vraag
die twee tussen haakjes zou ik zeggen zijn
ontkenningen, terwijl realisme en
instrumentalisme die
we suggereren als tegengestelden kunnen worden gezien
en ook helen longano's werk over
wetenschappelijk pluralisme heeft hier veel over te
zeggen door een
multidisciplinaire lens op realisme en
instrumentalisme
en dan zou decaan iets willen beschrijven
over deze toppaper die je vond
uh
ik zou kunnen ik kan me dit niet herinneren in de
grote schema's om eerlijk te zijn het is hier voor
mensen om te lezen er waren veel kranten
en  nogmaals, we plaatsen gewoon veel
tekst voor degenen die willen pauzeren en
de paden willen volgen
en het raakt allemaal verstrikt in
Stephen en  y opmerkingen over realisme-
instrumentalisme
Ik veronderstel dat het stuk
waar ik veel aan denk,
dit alles is, wordt dan
op een bepaald niveau ondersteund door actie, dus
het idee om te zoeken naar
verschillende
tegenstrijdigheden of verschillende
retro-
benaderingen
zou een geval kunnen zijn  Stel je voor dat
wanneer iemand erover denkt een pad
door het bos te nemen
, weet je of je veel van deze dingen opnieuw zou kunnen belichamen
of en misschien gaat alles op een bepaald
niveau door een of andere belichaming
um en wanneer het conceptueel
is, gebeurt die belichaming gewoon in  een meer
conceptuele
ruimte die niet afhankelijk is van zoveel andere
soorten verhalen of
je een weg door de dingen
banen, dus
het verschil dat er gebeurt als je
in een praktijkgebied bent, is dat je er zo aan
gewend bent om daarin te zijn  gebied van praktijk
dat
die belichaming het water wordt waarin
je zwemt,
dus dat zou iets kunnen zijn
dat verband houdt met deze
geweldige ja-decaan, gewoon heel snel, dus
nogmaals, we zullen op dit punt ja tegen
reali vragen  sm
ja tegen instrumentalisme
ja tot het einde
niet of
ongedaan gemaakt
we hadden een kleine ampersand hier en we
de en hier
een korte opmerking over voor e cognitie
we zullen hier niet in de diepte ingaan maar 4e kan
verwijzen naar de xiavio en van der
schiff 2018-paper die in de
context van muziekpedagogiek was, wat een
zeer fascinerend gebied is 4e is belichaamd
ingebed ingebed
uitgebreid uitgevaardigd
engecultiveerd enz enz enz 7e 11e 22e
allemaal en dan een leuk citaat van Carl
Fristen
van ons
symposium over toegepaste actieve inferentie in
hij zei dat een belangrijk ding over actieve
gevolgtrekking
is dat het voorbij voorspellende
verwerking gaat, het voorbij het gevoel gaat en het
benadrukt of weerspiegelt de pragmatische
wending aan het begin van deze eeuw,
echt belichaamd door de vier e's
om duidelijk te maken dat gevoel
actief is
en dat je het hebt  over
de circulaire causaliteit van betrokkenheid
bij een persoonlijk deeltje of plant met
wat er daarbuiten is paarse circulaire
causaliteit en dat alles houdt
dan vrij kort in  We gaan niet
in op al deze details, maar hier is een
heleboel werk dat relevant is voor de
inactieve krant,
alleen enkele van de andere
achtergrondcitaten en ander werk waar men naar zou
willen kijken
en voor de ontvoeringspaper
en ook een  een beetje leunen zelfs
in iets hopelijk kunnen de auteurs
voor ons uitpakken over de rol en
relatie van nominalisme met dit alles,
maar veel eerdere artikelen van de
auteurs hier
vermeld en weer veel geweldig werk, dus
bedankt jongens voor
deze reis
nu
we kunnen ingaan op de twee papieren of de
ruimte ertussen
laten we een eerste nevenschikking van
de twee papieren hebben ik zal onze video plaatsen zal
hier het topje van de ijsberg zijn dus decaan
jij bent het topje van de ijsberg wat zou
je willen zeggen  over deze twee artikelen
in een eerste nevenschikking
goed zoals ik al zei, ik denk dat
als je echt een stap terug doet en je realiseert
dat wat mensen doen door
te koppelen aan actieve gevolgtrekking,
je zegt dat
ik heb ik heb een bepaald soort  van
situationele analyse die ik zou
willen uitvoeren en daarbij zou ik
willen proberen om tegenstrijdigheden weg te nemen of ik
zou
integraties willen formuleren
en als je een stap terug doet naar die plaats
je
je voorbeeld van zo je je hyper je
hyper um
je hoofd je  onderwerp is sub uh
situationele analyse je voorbeeld
past daaronder dat
je nu niet
de fout maakt om te zeggen
mijn manier van doen kijken naar dingen
ontkent of verandert automatisch andere
manieren van kijken naar alles wat
onder die titel staat een situatie situationele
analyse vervaagt  nu
zijn er vergelijkingen en die zijn hier niet
geschreven en ze zijn zo klaar dat
ik in feite voorbeelden heb gekozen binnen
elk van de kranten waar
kranten het hebben over twee verschillende aandachtspunten,
maar ze zijn nog steeds binnen
deze grotere grotere
marginale
grens van actieve  gevolgtrekking en hoe
actief gevolgtrekking
zich gedraagt
et gedrag binne
een regime van aandacht en dat o
enstelt voor iets dat meer beschikbaar is dan d
bijzonderheden of het
schaalvriendelijke van gaat theory of mind noodzakelijkerwijs
samen
met actieve gevolgtrekking of
ontkent het idee dat ontvoering op het moment
dat ik aankom eigenlijk
elke mogelijkheid om
instrumenten te gebruiken om mijn mijn zintuiglijke venster goed te vergroten,
dus nogmaals, we gaan niet uitgeven
heel veel tijd
om die andere dingen eruit te halen, maar als
mensen echt willen zien hoe als
je ongeveer twee papieren naast elkaar legt,
je een hoop overeenkomsten kunt vinden,
het is best een interessante oefening, het
duurt even,
maar als je ze echt ziet  naast
elkaar en verstrikt er is een er wordt
veel gevlochten
dank je decaan stephen
ja ik vind dit leuk um
zoals dean het had daar heb
je deze twee papieren het zou bijna kunnen worden
gezien als twee ijsbergen waar
hun filosofieën vriendelijk zijn  van
bevroren en
gegeven vorm en vorm en er is spul
eronder en spul erboven,
maar er is ook het water
ertussenin
dat
veel uh garnalen kan hebben  en allerlei
dingen die rondzwemmen, dus
ik denk dat in deze lijst hier waar
je een soort realisme-
instrumentalisme hebt, nou, het zijn je twee
ijsbergen,
we willen dat ze mooi en scherp zijn
en misschien word je een beetje geslagen als je
knalt  uit hen en dan oke statistieken
en modelvergelijking
je weet
dat ze ze zijn nog steeds daar, maar
ze kunnen een beetje opschieten met multi-agent
geloof communicatie oh wacht even we hebben
hier iets stromende
dingen als samengestelde ensembles sorry
modellen als ensembles
perspectief
of panty's perspectief of waar komen die
perspectieven vandaan manieren om
stochasticiteit complexe systemen te kennen
enzovoort
eh
we zijn nu misschien
weet ik niet of we de ijsberg niet oplossen
dat gaat er niet over dat de
ijsberg er is, maar we zijn  het zijn
verschillende soorten um-
manieren
en om misschien flexibeler
en minder stabiel te worden,
geweldig dus in het inactieve papier gaan we
dus om de dingen redelijk te houden en
hebben ook veel te bespreken in de ene  en ten tweede
hebben we veel inhoud op de
dia's geplaatst zodat u kunt pauzeren en kunt genieten
van de meeste inhoud is gekopieerd en geciteerd
uit de krant, dus dat is het
referentiepunt voor meer informatie,
we zullen er gewoon doorheen lopen
in de volgorde van de routekaart  enkele van de
belangrijkste
stukken die de kranten doornemen, dus
in sectie één van de inactieve paper
beginnen ze met een
samenvatting
van vessier bij al's 2020-argument voor het
begrijpen van anderen in de wereld en
dat wordt gepresenteerd in dit denken
door andere geesten ttom papier  en dan is
tom theory of mind
ze vatten
of vangen het argument van het denken
door andere geesten als één
premisse één sociale cognitie is inactief
en belichaamd twee inactief en belichaamd
de sociale actor kan sociale cognitie niet direct vatten
drie alles wat niet direct kan worden
begrepen moet worden afgeleid
ergo qed conclusie inactieve en
belichaamde sociale cognitie moet worden
afgeleid, er moet gevolgtrekking zijn over
sociale cognitie
en de auteurs van de  inactief papier
stelt dat door uitgangspunt twee en drie
ttom aansluit bij de tom orthodoxie het
begrijpen van de wereld en anderen voor
hen komt neer op het vermogen om mentale toestanden af te leiden en to
te schrijven, dat i
de uh samenvatting van het denken door
ndere geesten en ze
gaan in twijfel trekk
n  op deze kritische ontleding dat zo'n
ttom-account inderdaad dit gelukkige
huwelijk maakt met een activisme dat
ze zullen aantrekken ja iedereen
of doorgaan oke ze gaan ze
gaan ze gaan een paar
verschillende van  deze premissen
en welke verborgen veronderstellingen ten grondslag kunnen liggen
aan die premissen, zoals welke
axioma's ertoe leiden dat iemand
zulke premissen genereert.  informatie
in expliciete propositievorm
mentale representatie en toeschrijving
ze gaan dit zeggen ze
voelen zich zo als een  mentale
representatie
en verborgen veronderstelling te sociale
cognitie is vastgebonden met de concepten
en logische hulpmiddelen voor gevolgtrekking, bijvoorbeeld
bij de geboorte
en in de volgende paragrafen
gaan ze de
tegenstelling tussen premissen één en
twee analyseren en verduidelijken
deze spanning van
als sociale cognitie is'  t actief en
belichaamd
is het echt zo of is het een
tegenstrijdige bewering
dat sociale cognitie niet direct kan worden
begrepen door zo'n sociale actor
dan gaan ze
vanuit het inactieve perspectief kritisch beoordelen welke
problemen aan deze aannames ten grondslag kunnen liggen
de verborgen aannames en
waarom  een activist verwerpt deze verborgen
veronderstellingen
en verwerpt daarom de hierboven genoemde premissen
en dan gaan ze onderzoeken
wat deze niet-representatieve
methoden en mechanismen van
co-constructie in sociale actie zijn
ze hebben een markov-deken
een visuele representatie die we hebben
hier eerder gezien
met de interne staten externe staten
en de bemiddeling van in  interne en
externe toestanden door algemene toestanden
die volgens de Pearl 1988-
definitie de algemene toestanden zijn die de
interne en externe toestanden
voorwaardelijk onafhankelijk maken
soms gaan mensen verder en beschrijven
een frisse deken waarbij de
dekentoestanden b
zijn verdeeld in twee soorten toestanden
zin en actief
en die twee soorten toestanden worden
gedefinieerd door hun inkomende vanuit het
perspectief van interne toestanden
statistische afhankelijkheden zintuiglijke toestanden
en uitgaande statistische afhankelijkheden
die kunnen worden geïnterpreteerd als acties of
interfaces van
de entiteit of het ding naar de niche,
maar we komen terug op markov-dekens
en later meer
ja, stephen ga ervoor
, kom er gewoon op terug,
eigenlijk de pagina de dia ervoor,
maar hiermee verband houdend is wanneer het zegt dat
dingen niet direct kunnen zijn, er zijn een
paar dingen die direct goed kunnen worden
begrepen, ik zou zeggen
dat dat een  nuttig onderscheid, want
als we denken aan eh, hebben we het
over de grip en  de greep of een
tang en ik kan een hete
pijp niet direct vastgrijpen ik heb de tang nodig ik kan
een aantal dingen niet direct doen zonder misschien
meer dan één gereedschap,
maar het gevoel bestaat dat
wanneer we het hebben over dingen vastpakken of
wanneer mensen nadenken over of
iets is,
je weet iets te begrijpen
dat expliciet proposities is,
je weet dat we andere soorten hulpmiddelen hebben
die misschien gaan spelen, zelfs als
we nadenken over woorden
en de handeling van het toeschrijven van
al deze dingen kan
optredens zijn met  tools op elk niveau,
dus
er is hier een interessante vermenging
gaande, afhankelijk van hoe
de ijsberg geweldig wordt gesmolten
in sectie twee
die je in de krant kunt lezen of
hier kunt pauzeren en veel aspecten ervan kunt vastleggen,
ze gaan de veronderstelling in twijfel trekken
dat sociale cognitie wordt gereduceerd tot mentale
representatie
en
hun punt kan worden gedestilleerd, aangezien het
begrijpen van anderen een kwestie is
van vaardigheid in gedeelde niet-expliciete
betekenissen
en mogelijk enige
ontvoering
ding-ding-ding en modelgebaseerd redeneren
die allemaal contextspecifiek
aanpasbaar en dynamisch zijn
en ze zullen in de
verdere paragrafen uitpakken dat daarin
een duidelijke tegenstrijdigheid ligt tussen die
eerste twee premissen, die eigenlijk
de achilleshiel is  of de zwakke plek waar
ze hun logica
in sectie twee gaan richten,
ze gaan die tweede van de veronderstellingen in twijfel trekken,
namelijk dat sociale
cognitie vanaf de geboorte
vastligt en dus hoewel ze de ttom-positie kwalificeren
en ze zeggen vessier doen  bijvoorbeeld geen
nativistische positie innemen als een
puur aangeboren perspectief
omdat ze zich wel richten op de
ontwikkelings- en ecologische dynamiek van
hoe cultuur wordt verworven, stellen
ze de
aanschaf van het starterspakket in twijfel
en onderzoeken ze ook meer in deze
sectie  sommige inactivistische kritieken van
bijvoorbeeld vastgebonden perspectieven op sociale
cognitie
in sectie 3
met kritiek op aannames die in
hun gedachten benadrukken  de tegenstrijdigheid die
inherent is aan het denken door andere
geesten ze gaan een andere
relatie suggereren oh je houdt niet van dat gerecht
laten we deze eens proberen
en dit wordt een
benadering van de dynamische systeemtheorie
of dst schrijven ze
dst
zoals we zullen betogen in  deze sectie is een
benadering die dient om te leren over en
voorspellende kracht te genereren over de
sociaal-cultureel gesitueerde praktijken van
agenten die hun niche construeren,
omdat dst in de kern
nuttige hulpmiddelen heeft zoals opkomst,
non-lineariteit en spontaniteit enz.
het stelt ons in staat om afstand te nemen van
geprefabriceerde noties  van tom theory of
mind-achtige theorieën van sociale cognitie
moet men zich daarom onthouden van het maken van
ontologische veronderstellingen,
hier gaat het over hoe de
dingen in de wereld zijn,
dus meer van de ontologie van de filosofen in
plaats van de informatica
kennisbeheerszin van ontologie
moet men zich onthouden van het maken van  dit
soort ontologische veronderstellingen
gelicentieerd door het realisme
over het complex  systeem gebaseerd op een
handelbaar model,
dus alleen omdat het model zo
handelbaar is,
betekent niet dat we de licentie
hebben om ontologische veronderstellingen te maken,
aangezien het handelbare model een
kans is om over het complexe gedrag te leren.
alleen epistemische beweringen
zijn toegestaan.
kijk naar de claim
om het handelbaar te maken, we kunnen een
dynamisch systeem
als volgt weergeven door een statische relatie en hier zijn
hun vergelijkingen een, twee en drie met
de onderstaande bijschriften
en ze gebruiken deze heel
eenvoudige soort, zoals de kern van de
dynamische systemen  theorie is
begrijpen hoe
dingen een functie zijn van hoe ze in het
algemeen veranderen en het wordt op een paar
verschillende manieren weergegeven
in termen van een opvolgermodel en
meer een straal van veranderingsmodel
stephen
ik denk dat dit een zeer
nuttig punt is punt nummer drie daar
de opsomming  punt, want het spreekt ook
tot dat gevoel
hiervan is een modelleringsbenadering
laten we eens kijken wat het model
ons vertelt in plaats van een modelaanpassing
benader
eh, wat vaak is dat je weet wat er
gebeurt als je de gedefinieerde
ontologie
hebt, je weet in feite
zoveel dingen, dus
dat is misschien een belangrijk
stuk
dat
veel verbindt van hoe dingen kunnen worden overbrugd in
termen van actieve gevolgtrekking en hoe het
zou kunnen  tussen jullie gehouden worden
weet
dat dat een
is een houding in zekere
zin is het dat het de benen uit elkaar houdt en
zegt
oke
doe ik de splitsingen of heb ik mijn
benen goed bij
elkaar dus
laten we het uitzoeken in plaats van
dat iemand deskundige mij um vertelt
en
ja
bedankt bedankt decaan ja
ja ik wilde gewoon toevoegen aan wat
Stephen net zei ik
tot nu toe ik echt en ik hou van
het papier
dat het het constructivistische stuk is
hoewel ik
denk dat het me
even laat pauzeren omdat ik geloof
dat
om die beslissing te kunnen
nemen,
zijn het de splitsingen of is het een splitsing is het
letterlijk een splitsing en in plaats van van
links naar rechts te moeten gaan, is een deconstructie vereist
waarvan ik denk dat deze vaak vooraf wordt weggelaten
naar een reconstructie,
dus nogmaals, ik ga niet in discussie met de
auteurs omdat ik denk dat
ze de autonomie respecteren
en ik denk dat ze briljant werk hebben geleverd
door te zeggen oké deze logica dit deductieve
pad dat andere auteurs hebben genomen, is hier
misschien niet per se van toepassing  omdat
het te veel vermenging veroorzaakt, zo goed goed
goed jij je houdt omhoog wat
eigenlijk links en rechts is,
maar je laat de toevoeging
de en deel is dat het een vork kan zijn die
ik letterlijk zou kunnen oppakken en de  de enige
manier waarop je dat kunt zien is als je kunt
deconstrueren
voordat je reconstrueert en deconstrueren
betekent niet differentiëren dat is
al aanwezig deconstrueren
betekent letterlijk als
de eenheid
wanneer kwam ik op dit moment wat
heb ik welke delen van de puzzel
mis ik nog  omdat
ik haast heb om erachter te komen of ik
links of rechts moet gaan,
vooral in de totale context, vooral
daar
ja stephen als je hier een
snel punt wilt geven, bedankt, gewoon toevoegen aan
dat um
dat stukje van de situationalness
um ik
geloof dat dat is waar je je
bewust wordt van wat er gaande is, dus de wetenschap
vertelt ons heel erg wat er aan de hand is
wat is dat ding wat is
dit wat is dat
anders dan die splitsing in de weg of dat je
weet wat er aan de hand is  team team leeftijdsovergang of
iets anders
uiteindelijk is er een stukje bewustzijn
waar is dat gesitueerd en in actieve
gevolgtrekking die vaak
complexer is, vaag
met het wetenschappelijke wezen over de
nauwkeurigheid
van de methode, maar
andere keren dat het bewustzijn en de
complexiteit komt in actieve gevolgtrekking
kan beide hebben  die ja geweldig gaan
door tot de laatste delen van het artikel
ze praten veel over complexiteit waar
velen van ons van houden
zo complexiteit complexiteit wetenschap
complexiteit theorie brengt zoveel
geweldige
termen concepten mensen methoden tools
ideeën alles
en ze praten veel over autopolicies
en deze recursiviteit  dus er zijn
veel echt creatieve koppelingen gemaakt
in het inactieve papier en de complexiteit is
op een heel waardevolle manier gebruikt
in sectie vier
, gaan ze over op actieve
inferentie in een inactieve dynamische omgeving
en dat is waar actieve inferentie
zal worden ingezet als een inzichtelijk
instrument om te leren over en inzicht te krijgen in
de dynamiek die ten grondslag ligt aan culturele
co-constructies
gezien het niet noodzakelijkerwijs
agenten als passieve
agenten nodig heeft, zijn samen de auteurs van de
toestanden van elkaar
en
zo min of meer analoog aan de inactieve
figuren die eerder werden getoond, waar we de
tandwielen in het hoofd hadden
en toen ging het erom dat de
tandwielen meer verdeeld waren  in het lichaam en
in de geest
hier in figuur 2 is er meer een
klassieke
betekenis en op modellen gebaseerde redenering waarbij
verschillende sociale actoren een soort
van inferentiële verklaring hebben die
erg op één richting lijkt, zoals hier getoond
met een pijl die net naar het
midden wijst en  in figuur 3 geven ze
de sociale actie in figuur 2 weer onder
actieve gevolgtrekking in termen van het labelen van
hier
de interne toestanden  van de sociale actor
en de externe staten zijn sociale
actor één, dus dit is vanuit het
perspectief van sociale actor twee,
waar de algemene staten worden
geframed als sociaal-culturele betekenis en die op
modellen gebaseerde redenering
die zich opent voor inferentiële rekeningen
die worden verspreid
en vastgesteld
en
[Muziek]
hopelijk zullen we meer in detail treden,
want dit is waar ze
hun positieve
instrumentalistische toepassing van actieve
gevolgtrekking in de sociale inactieve ruimte ondersteunen
en dan schrijven ze een
sociale scène karakteriserend als analoog aan de wetenschappelijke
praktijk
is er door een verkeerde karakterisering het is
bijna  zoals nemen wat er in het
laboratorium gebeurt in een bepaalde context en zelfs
een bepaalde kijk op wat er gebeurt in het
laboratorium in een bepaalde context
komma in een bepaalde context
en dat dan bekritiseren
en wat uitgebreider nadenken
over wat er gebeurt in de gangen van
het laboratorium  en in de kelder en
in de wereld rondom het gebouw
en dat is ook r  heel mooi verbonden
met een of andere gele bronberg het werk aan
het anticiperende brein is geen
wetenschapper die zich ook richt op het
inactieve perspectief vanuit een ecologisch
perspectief niet alleen noodzakelijk het
sociale maar het sociale is een belangrijk
geval
in tabel 1
die ze gaan bespreken  een beetje
meer over
enkele van de verdelers en inhoud van
cellen die verband houden met de natuurlijke wereld en
wetenschappelijke hulpmiddelen en constructies,
we komen hier zeker terug in
volgende discussies, dus kijk maar eens naar
tabel één,
kijk wat je denkt,
welke andere regels zou je willen  zouden
ze een beetje op gebogen lijnen
lijken, zoals letters, zou je
iets omcirkelen zou je wat driehoeken tekenen
zou je nog een rij toevoegen zou je
er een tensor van maken wat zou je nog meer op
tafel één tekenen
, al was het maar een andere dubbele
begrenzingslijn om te benadrukken  dat het perfect is, zoals
decaan, ik zou alleen maar zeggen dat als je dit
gaat bekijken, je jezelf afvraagt waarom deze hyper
arameters en waarom deze
aat  rals
omdat ik denk dat
dat zal leiden tot allerlei soorten
goed voor mij, het maakte me zo verdraaid
leuk,
oké en dan de conclusie voordat we
naar het tweede artikel gaan dat
we hebben laten zien dat het vasthouden van zowel een
activisme als een theory of mind tegenstrijdigheid met zich meebrengt
en  verwarring
dit wordt duidelijk wanneer we
de twee verborgen veronderstellingen
van tom kritisch ontleden zoals theorieën zoals ttom die
worden verworpen door inactivisme die twee
heimelijke veronderstellingen die volgens hen
de koppeling in diskrediet brengen
en dan
herhalen ze de co-constructieve
aard en de ingebedde en ecologische
componenten  van sociale passiviteit
en de recursie en het zich ontvouwen
in de tijd, het uitrollen van sociale
passiviteit
en ze suggereren dat dynamische systeemtheorie
en actieve gevolgtrekking instrumenteel
toegepast als een soort dynamische
systeemmodellering veelbelovend is
en een geschikt en aanvullend hulpmiddel is
om sociaal begrip te beschouwen als
gegeneraliseerde
synchronisatie op een bepaalde manier gehouden,
dus dat was dat p  aper en
het zal nu worden
gecombineerd met het ontvoeringspapier, dus
één ademteug voordat we overgaan tot ontvoering
ja stephen
die adem haalt eh die laatste zin
daar over hoe het
bijna een brug kan zijn ze zijn het
complementaire um
gebruik van dynamische systeemtheorie
en een soort leemte
opvullen, ze vullen de leemte op een bepaalde manier, denk ik, terwijl
we praten over de ontvoeringspapieren,
enkele leemten die niet opvullen,
ik weet dat we hier niet proberen te praten over het
opvullen van leemten, maar  laten we zeggen dat je
leemten opvult
ontvoering
kan ook voelen, dus je weet dat
de schoonheid van de schoonheid van actieve
gevolgtrekking en de bayesiaanse benadering is
dat er veel verschillende
schalen en modaliteiten zijn en kunnen worden
gewogen en gemengd om je
mogelijk een gevoel te geven
voor wat  om het goed te doen, zodat
het niet betekent dat het een het ander uitsluit
geweldig
oke
tussen ontvoering
we stompen weg
het artikel begint met een relatief
korte en zeer beknopte
inleiding tot enkele van de belangrijkste punten
van het papier dat
we eerder beschreven  In hun doel dat
ze geïnteresseerd zijn in deze naturalistische
weergave
van sommige van cs pierce's later,
bijv. post 1903 of post 1905,
grotendeels ongepubliceerd werk dat
de semiotische en logische
noties van abductief redeneren uitpakt, die we hebben
behandeld in de contextsectie,
streven ze naar dit
biologisch ontvoeringsmodel
dat
de naald gaat
rijgen weven de stof wat het ook is
dat de functionele integriteit
van het organisme handhaaft
de evolutionaire noodzaak voor
het bestaan van dat levende wezen en om compa
ibel te zijn met de moderne neurowetenschap ze ri
hten zich op de loyaliteit en de allia
tie die we  eerder besproken
en ze zullen ook in de
inleiding het Markov-dekenconcept introduceren,
wat een geweldig
juxtapositiepunt zal zijn om een beetje meer details toe te voegen, zoals
als het een front is, een conta
tfront met actieve gevolgtrekking met sociale inact
viteit en ontvoering dan d
ze  zijn als hotspots
of contactpunten binnen de interface om
echt in te zoomen, oké hoe  wordt de interne
toestand gebruikt in deze twee modellen en
dat is waar de actieve inferentie-
ontologie van enorme waarde is, want
zelfs wanneer mensen in
verschillende talen spreken of we een
computerprogramma hebben, een vergelijking, een gedicht en
dan een wetenschappelijk artikel
wanneer we kunnen linken en proactief  gebruiken of
proactief annoteren met de actieve
inferentie-ontologie
we krijgen het vermogen om niet alleen goed te zeggen
we wijzen allebei naar de maan
is jouw vinger mijn vinger of
wijzen we naar dezelfde vinger omdat het
zo ver weg is en dus misschien een beetje
beetje af en je straal mist de
maan vanuit mijn oogpunt
enzovoort, in plaats daarvan kunnen we echt naar
beneden gaan en niet
doodbloeden op de operatietafel,
maar eerder tijdelijk vastpinnen en
een aantrekker vinden die ons helpt echt
dat kruispunt in te gaan.  dan alleen maar
slaan en rennen met alleen
resonantiepunten decaan
ja nogmaals
ik zal dat gewoon samenvatten door te zeggen dat
we situationeel beter kunnen analyseren omdat
we nu eigenlijk h  Ik heb
een manier om iets
gemeenschappelijks
bij elkaar te houden,
dus dat is alles wat ik wil toevoegen aan wat je
net zei
en er ook nog een aan toevoegen
is ja sorry maar eh
en waar er een verschil kan zijn,
dus
je weet zoals
er kan dit begrip zijn van
veel van de termen het ontologische
begrip en zeggen
wat vaak een probleem is, is als er
iets is dat niet op één
lijn ligt, maar
gewoon niet wordt opgemerkt of wordt overgeslagen zeg
oke dit is anders oke er is een
ontologische verandering hier is
er een  er is een
manier om dat handelbaar te maken
zoals we hebben met actieve gevolgtrekking het is
een handelbare manier om het te doen omdat er
anders zoveel ontologische
dingen rondzweven in deze ruimte,
wat zijn schoonheid is
dat het cognitief niet mogelijk is
om te vinden wat je zoekt  moet opnieuw naar
het volgende gedeelte kijken
, met deze twee lichten
co-verlichtend co-construeren
geen twee lichten kunnen elkaar fysiek overlappen, dus
er moet parallax worden veroorzaakt  door deze
twee lichten en schaduwen en allerlei
effecten en misschien is het niet dezelfde
golflengte en misschien loop je
rond en hebben verschillende kanten
verschillende verlichtingen
de sectie is op actieve gevolgtrekking in
het licht van ontvoering
dit
is een zeer
fascinerende sectie
omdat ze'  We gaan dat
bijna
quasi-algoritmische
maar zeker
pre-computationele
raamwerk
dat in de laatste jaren 1800
en vroege jaren 1900 werd ontwikkeld, gebruiken
en beginnen met de
interface en zien
hoe het zich verhoudt tot actieve inferentie,
zodat we meer kunnen benadrukken en we kijken
ernaar uit om in  verdere
secties dus pauzeer het als je
dit allemaal wilt lezen of de krant wilt lezen,
maar ze concentreren zich op het late schema
ja alsjeblieft, decaan, alles wat ik wilde zeggen
is dat het sfeerverlichting is als je
echt naar de onderste kogel kijkt
verlichting is eigenlijk proberen
portemonnee sprak erover misschien
weet ik misschien niet of hij echt de
formalismen had om dat te staven,
maar actieve gevolgtrekking praat nu echt
over een  over het soort
energieniveau
dat we nu kunnen
zien binnen de twee
beperkingen dat dat idee om
terug te parametriseren naar de bankschroef,
zoiets
dank je, dus slechts een paar citaten die
hier echt fascinerend zijn,
dus
in wetenschappelijke ontvoering  kan worden vergeleken met
de logica van het ontdekken van hypothesen
die, zoals we eerder hebben besproken, een
generatief creatief element hebben en vervolgens een
secundaire selectieve component zoals
bayesiaanse modelselectie, bayesiaanse modelreductie
en ze voegen er zelfs aan toe met een waarschuwende
opmerking dat er geen volledige
assimilatie van Pearson-ontvoering kan
plaatsvinden  volgens mij is dat een gevolgtrekking naar de
beste verklaring, namelijk de helft van
de tweetaktmotor en gewoonlijk gebruiken
mensen ontvoering om te verwijzen naar
probabilistische redeneringen uit een bepaalde reeks,
zoals ontvoering elders in de geschriften
dit latere schema
die van na 1903
maar
volgens  voor experts zijn er de minste
onderzoeken geweest
die beginnen met een observatie van
verrassende factor e  ventileert
observatie verrassing
en concludeert via een conditionele major
premisse in een cohortatieve stemming weer een
stemming
die pieren genoemd de onderzoeker
het is zoals het is en juist daarin
en dat is dat er iets van dwingend
belang moet worden gedaan
pragmatisme inactiviteit beleidskeuze
aanvankelijk gewekt  door nieuwsgierigheid
onzekerheid reductie entropie
die leidt tot de formulering van een
vraag
die semantisch is
en
er is meer discussie over de
onderzoekende stemming en andere stemmingen
ja dean een ander snel ding
gecohord of gecoconstrueerd uit het
andere papier opnieuw
delen een gemeenschappelijk voorvoegsel dat we
opnieuw  ik denk dat ik daar misschien
wat meer van kan plagen
het belang daarvan in de komende
livestreams
geweldig
ze gaan door met deze
kwestie van de economie van onderzoek,
dus
vormden ze drie argumentatieve cursus
echt gespecificeerde contactgebieden met
actieve gevolgtrekking  en ontvoering die
ze voorstellen om een eerste trio of dr
etal te vormen dat z
l schitteren  Om de loyaliteit
tussen actieve en abductieve gevolgtrekking te vormen,
eerst de aanwezigheid van
niet-degeneratieve triadische relaties,
vervolgens het gebruik van de leidende
principes van abductief redeneren
b en ten derde de conjunctieve voorwaardelijke
formulering
zijn er enkele logische technische
details, maar
daar zijn de stromen voor
in punt a
waar je even kunt pauzeren en de tekst kunt lezen
gaan ze het concept van de Markov-deken benadrukken
of liever
hun realistische
interpretatie als frist en dekens
en
beweren
dat
de Markov-dekens opnieuw geïmplementeerd in
een realistische eerste en algemene
zin een duidelijk doordringende
onherleidbaar triadische vorm
gericht op de grens als bemiddelaar
tussen externe interne toestanden en
daarom de derdeheid die ontstaat in
semiosis
er is veel meer te zeggen, maar als een
van jullie nog een punt wil geven op a
oke in b
gaan ze verder met  praten
over enkele van de leidende principes van
gevolgtrekking
en specifiek bespreken ab  de
rol van ductie bij het leiden van gevolgtrekkingen
wat is het leidende principe van actieve
gevolgtrekkingen dan
gaan ze hier enkele
technische details van actieve gevolgtrekking beschrijven in
termen van vrije energie variatie of
verwacht als grensverrassing
en dan zullen ze dat verbinden met enkele van
de primaire  bronnen van doorboring en
discussies over biosemiotica die
ook verband houden met veel
discussies die we hebben gehad over
representatie en betekenis enzovoort
en
het gaat zelfs nog verder of dieper weg
met discussies over
synechisme en deze
kwestie van universele geest die  is
kracht veroudering in sommige opzichten de universele
cognitie pan cognitieve dynamiek
gedistribueerde cognitieve systemen
materie is een lege geest door von schiller
en dan gaan ze discussiëren over
ongerepte dekens en hun constructie
in termen van triadische relaties
peerson triade teken object interpreteren en
leidt tot onontgonnen  semantische
mogelijkheden
die enkele van deze bredere
kwalitatieve draden samenbrengen i  n semiotische analyse
met potentieel dynamische
systeemtheorie kwantitatieve bayesiaanse methoden en
al het andere dat actieve gevolgtrekking met zich
meebrengt, samen met de toolkits om te
implementeren
en zie dat
ze ook in c ga een aantal
uiterst
interessante maar genuanceerde logische
constructieve elementen
van
de semiotische propositie uitpakken
als ik kon  noem het die
er meer
op ingaan in verdere discussies,
maar ze gaan onderzoeken
hoe verschillende
framingen van logische relaties
tussen clausules of beweringen en
rechtvaardigingen en al deze retoriek
verband houden met
realisme
ontvoering
en
doorboren's versie van realisme, aangezien het
mogelijke is wat echt kan worden
ja er zijn dingen die mogelijk zijn
maar niet actueel kunnen worden en wat
gebruiken we dan voor dat aangrenzende of
realiseerbare
mogelijke
en
waar zouden we het kunnen gebruiken en wat
gaat die symmetrie doorbreken waar is
pragmatisme goed wat zou nuttig zijn om te
overwegen zou zijn  de ruimte van alle
mogelijke dingen die kunnen gebeuren en geen
andere en n  laat je niet verrassen door aangrenzende
mogelijkheden die we niet hebben overwogen maar
zijn gebeurd
en dan is het misschien niet zo erg
om wat extra aandacht of een paar
extra computerbronnen te besteden aan het overwegen van
mogelijkheden die niet zouden kunnen gebeuren,
maar die we niet zouden willen  verdwalen in de
potentieel exponentiële ruimte van
mogelijkheden die niet kunnen gebeuren
en uiteindelijk onze focus en
aandacht verliezen op mogelijkheden die kunnen
gebeuren, wat pierce beschrijft
als echte mogelijkheden
en de pragmatische houding
en
stemming sluit ook de cirkel met
beleidsselectie en  pragmatisme in actieve
gevolgtrekking
waar ze zeggen dat de pragmatische
betekenis van overtuigingen in de bane paris-
formulering
datgene is waarnaar men in
staat is te handelen
en er is veel resonantie daar
stephen
ja, ik denk dat dit ook spreekt tot
de noodzaak om te hebben
we praten over schaalvriendelijk of niveaus
of
je kent een soort structuur waardoor
dit aanwezig kan zijn omdat
je weet dat actieve invloed dat kan  rt van
helemaal naar beneden gaan en naar
het cellulaire niveau brengen, want er zijn manieren om hier
naar te kijken
, er is een gevoel dat oké, we
kijken naar
deze um-
ideeën van um een betekenaar, maar
e weten met actieve gevolgtrekking dat het niet
o is  is van mening dat er
signalen binnenkomen die worden verwerkt
en geaggregeerd,
dus er is een soort schaal
waarop je de structuren hebt waarop
je de
morfogenese hebt, misschien om
een schaal te krijgen om het s
opteken logisch te ma
en om te worden geïn
erpreteerd als zijn  eige
betekenaar, dus ik denk dat dat
de spanning kan zijn
tussen de inactivisten hier en en
waar dat kan gebeuren, maar het argument
zou heel goed kunnen zijn dat ik zou zeggen dat bepaalde
schalen
bepaalde structuren
en misschien bepaalde realistische
manieren waarop dingen gebeuren
zoiets als  dat
kan
prima gewoon decaan en dan gaan we
snel door de rest laat me gewoon
heel snel zijn hier denk ik vooral in b
en en tot in mindere mate en c
de bus  De manier waarop we piercings
doordringend
denken
in het actieve inferentierijk brengen,
is gebaseerd op een veronderstelling en dat is
dat het voortzetten van ons
voortbestaan onze voortdurende reali
eit um betek
nt dat we meer ervar
ngen opdoen met de tools in de
wereld de regels in de wereld  wereld en
de poelen en met poelen bedoel ik die
aggregaties waar Stephen net
naar wees om je te bedanken dat je dat ter sprake
bracht steven omdat dat me ertoe bracht
deze aggregaties op te schrijven als
dichtheden
verhaal van twee dichtheden die zich materialiseren
dus nogmaals ik weet niet
dat je
uitsluitend zeggen dat alles echt is en
dan zijn alle voorbeelden eronder
ook echt omdat zelfs Pierce zelf
zei dat er een aspect van deze
realiteit is dat we nooit
zullen kunnen omschrijven als iets anders
dan
niet-realiteit,
ook al gebruiken we fundamenteel  het
dus hoe werkt dat
hoe zorgt dat
ervoor dat deze dichtheden zich kunnen vormen en ik
weet dat dat verdomd klinkt en daar is weggegaan Het
spijt me, maar het is  eigenlijk iets waar we
over moeten nadenken,
bedankt dat
ze dan
het script of op zijn minst de syntaxis gaan omdraaien
en over ontvoering praten in het licht van
actieve gevolgtrekking,
hier beginnen ze met die
erkenning van de tweetaktmotor
met generatieve ontvoering en  selectieve
ontvoering
en dan gaan ze dat
verbinden met een deel van de ontologie van actieve
gevolgtrekking in termen van het zien van
selectieve ontvoering
als een steekproefproces
en begrijpen waar generatieve
ontvoering past,
dus doorgaan met het zien van ontvoering
vanuit het licht van actieve gevolgtrekking die
we zouden zelfs kunnen operationaliseren door te zeggen
dat we
ontvoering inlijsten of bekijken
vanuit het perspectief van de actieve
inferentie-ontologie,
dus in plaats van dat we
zelf kiezen
als interpretatie van actieve inferentie als
een
concept waarvan we niet noodzakelijkerwijs kunnen
spreken voor een concept dat
we niet voor Engels kunnen spreken, maar  we
kunnen Engelse woorden gebruiken
en dus hoeven we niet per se te
spreken voor actieve infe
Hoewel ik de laatste ben om te zeggen wat die wel
of niet zouden moeten doen
, is het mogelijk
om de actieve inferentie-ontologie te gebruiken en
dan is het een beetje alsof een
checklist in twee stappen de term was in de daad van inferentie-
ontologie in het kernsupplement of
secties met zich meebracht,
werd het gebruikt
op een pragmatische manier die
logisch was in die situatie
in die multischaalcontext
en dat is eigenlijk een proces in twee stappen om
te vragen of we spreken
met actieve gevolgtrekking in plaats van of
we spreken voor  als een pleitbezorger of
als een verkoper voor actieve gevolgtrekking
per se
en ze gaan de zaak herhalen in
termen van het fap-raamwerk in de zin
van en met behulp van de voorwaarden van
en ze gaan de
relatie van interne toestanden
met externe benadrukken  toestanden bemiddeld door de
deken
en ze gaan dan door dit syllogisme
en ze herstructureren en herformuleren hun
kwalitatieve schema van abductieve actieve
gevolgtrekking
en ze beschrijven deze
actie-cognitie-perceptielus
waar
een surp  Als er binnenkomende
sensorische informatie wordt ervaren
, nemen ze dat niet alleen mee in de passieve
of zelfs actieve interpretatie ervan
in de context van een bayesiaans generatief
model,
maar eerder in iets dat zich ontvouwt
in die stemming van de onderzoeker die
ze wel doorzetten
en binnenhalen  uh belangrijk doordringend idee
van de economie van onderzoek,
dus we zullen dit opnieuw bespreken, hopelijk
met de auteurs.
Het heeft betrekking op de
wetenschapstheorie van
Pierce Pierce's originele artikel in 1970 of 1876
over de economie van onderzoek
schreef de doctrine van economie in het algemeen
behandelt de relaties  tussen nut
en kosten
en in het bijzonder dat zal worden
gerelateerd aan onderzoek in deze sociaal
geëngageerde pragmatische zin
door te vragen hoe gezien de besteding van geld,
tijd en energie
wat de meest waardevolle
toevoeging aan kennis zal opleveren
welk experiment waar mijn ogen naar zouden kunnen
cicade  hebben de meeste informatie
krijgen
welke experimenten de onderzoeker zou kunnen
uitvoeren om hun onzekerheid te verminderen
het meeste over het natuurlijke systeem
niet alleen om iets te verifiëren waarvan ze weten
niet alleen om iets te vervalsen waarvan
ze weten dat het zal worden vervalst, maar eerder
om te bestaan in deze optimale experimenteerruimte en da
door te dringen en later gaan de auteu
s naturaliseren contextualiseren breng
n naar de sociale  cognitief gebied
door goed te vragen hoe geld, tijd en
energie gebeurt, omdat dat optimale
experiment in cultuur is en het
energie gebruikt, het gebruikt reagentia, dus misschien
zouden we op deze manier kunnen zeggen dat
pierce een van de eerste moderne programmamanagers was
voor een grote financieringsinstantie, maar  nee dat
was hij niet en ze bespraken deze economie
van onderzoek een beetje meer
ze beschrijven in deze sectie
hoe
pierce verschillende
waarden of deugden of kwaliteiten promoot
die de economie van het
maken van wetenschappelijke hypothesen karakteriseren
in complexiteit
die is als een risicovrije
breedte
die spreekt tot  eenwording
en voorzichtigheid
als de economische kwaliteit van het vermijden van
afnemende marginale opbrengsten
door vakkundig te breken  vragen
opsplitsen in een reeks kleine vragen die
kunnen worden beantwoord met
redelijke investeringslimieten
hoeveel interessante threads worden
samengebracht,
bijvoorbeeld vragen die zijn
opgesplitst in binair ja nee vragen
kunnen ook worden verbonden met informatietheorie
en kwantum
hier decaan  ik zal je laten
spreken tot eerlijkheid
ik zal het gewoon lezen om eerlijk te zijn en zoals
kort aan het begin van dit artikel
zijn er geen instrumentalistische
interpretaties van fep en zijn
ingrediënten zoals markov dekens
maar
dit is een voetnoot in dit artikel maar ons
geloof  voor een van een beter woord en
realistische geloofsbrieven van fep als zijn wortels
in het pragma pragmatische optimisme of
liever zijn daad van verbetering van de
voordelen van de alliantie tussen
evolutionair evolutionair bruikbare
processen om bij te dragen aan het maximaliseren van
overleving
als deze pragmatische benadering van
realisme de verhevene mishaagt  smaak van iemand die op
zoek is naar een aantal stevige metafysische
criteria laat duizend
bloemen bl  oom, ik denk dat het
fascinerende hieraan is
dat het idee dat er een realisme
is een heel gemakkelijk verdedigbare positie is om in te
nemen, maar zelfs in de vorige dia een
van de dingen waar
het voor het
eerst over ging zonder ze direct te zeggen
of in ieder geval niet in  die citaten
waren dat
die optimale positie een
element van uitbuiting of economie
of eenvoud is of dat iemand dit
voor mij
heeft gedaan is dat een kortere weg
en verkenning die de neiging heeft om langer te duren,
meer
vallen en opstaan heeft, maar
e ook niet constant overm
tig laat passe
naar een bepaalde uitkomst
dus
eh
dat is de realiteit
en nogmaals, ik zou niet
teruggaan op de bewering dat er een heel
echt
stuk in dit
spel zit
speel minimaal twee heen en
weer in dit
um
dus
ik ben  niet alleen in feite ben ik het volledig eens met
deze auteurs zoals ik het volledig eens ben met
de andere auteurs
over het idee van een co-constructie, dus ik
weet niet dat
jij jij jij bent
je bent noodzakelijkerwijs in de war als  je
kunt ja en ja en nogmaals ja zeggen
steven
ja een beetje toevoegen aan wat daar te
zeggen en
het idee van
implementatie of
exploitatie wordt zeker genoemd
en in de
wetenschap is
experimenteren een soort manier
om kennis te vergaren,
maar er is het verkenningsstuk en  mijn
ik zou beweren dat
je niet
per se verkenning kunt krijgen binnen
het soort
objectieve domein dat er moet zijn deze
reis naar het in het naar het
performatieve subjectieve naar het subjectieve
liminale
zoals einstein deed met zijn hersenspelletjes al
deze en je creëert dit soort  van
mentale uh construeert op een manier wat een deel
van wat er vandaag gebeurt een mengsel
daarvan is en dan wordt dat teruggebracht
en gemodelleerd, geëxperimenteerd met wat dan ook,
dus ik denk dat er een ik bedoel, modelleren is
interessant omdat
het eh het soort van kan komen op die
reis een  een klein beetje ook,
dus
dat kan iets zijn dat
experimenten niet kunnen doen
hier is een samenvatting van een oude grap persoon a
zegt a
en de ref  eree zegt dat je gelijk hebt persoon
b zegt b de scheidsrechter zegt dat je gelijk hebt
en persoon c zegt goed a en b kan
niet kloppen en de scheidsrechter zegt dat je weet
dat je gelijk hebt
het is een beetje snelle humor voor degenen die
dat leuk vinden  genre
um ze hebben dan een conclusiesectie
en
we hebben veel vragen en punten om te
maken en veel verbanden om
veel van de naturalisatie hier terug te brengen,
zoals de velden in Levin
Work en ze nemen het zelfs mee naar de
regeneratieve capaciteiten van platwormen dus
van
platte wormen tot huisgenoten,
dat is waar we vandaag naar toe gaan
en dan hebben we ook voor de punt
één een
deel van de nevenschikking van het Markov-dekenconcept gespaard, met
name
de sociale en actieve componenten van de
wetenschap die super belangrijk zijn en
majeed heeft deze tot stand gebracht
discussies eerder is een geweldig
contactpunt met het ontvoerende papier en
de sociaal inactieve papieren
markov-dekens vormen een zeer
beperkt, zelfs technisch
contactfront dat veel discussie zal opleveren
ion in de punt één
en dat is waar
we de punt nul afsluiten
met uh
weer zoveel uitstekend grondwerk en
rugzakverpakking
door decaan en steven, dus
is er nog iets dat je
op dit punt zou willen toevoegen of iets dat
naar voren komt dat je wilt bespreken  in de punt één ja
decaan dan stephen als je Daniel
fantastisch werk wilt, we hebben zojuist een orde van
grootte 3 gedaan van wat normaal een
enkele livestream op papier was en we hebben het nog
steeds binnen twee uur, zodat je
je bent  om daarvoor toegejuicht te worden en
ten tweede wil ik
misschien als een tip voor de
punt één er is een onderzoek met de
naam israel israel nunez die praat over
als je wilt kunnen
kijken hoe dingen worden gedeconstrueerd  en
geconstrueerd, je moet naar zowel het
product in het proces kijken, een voorbeeld is hoe
ik een auto bouw
en in het product verwerk
wat is het ding dat ofwel een
vertakkingspunt of een echt gebruiksvoorwerp is
en dus als je als je je geest openstelt
voor  zowel die
inversie als dat  continuüm
het opent allerlei
mogelijkheden om dingen op een plaats te brengen
waar ze niet noodzakelijk in
conflict komen, ja ze kunnen integreren in vlechten
en dus misschien zal dat
na vandaag
iets zijn dat mensen die
actieve gevolgtrekking gebruiken, wat in mijn  mening is
zowel product als proces en proces en
product
tegelijk het is de grijper en
de greep misschien zullen ze er misschien
over nadenken
het is bijna alsof de pragmaticus de
vork in de weg ziet en deze gebruikt
en misschien jij  gebruik de vork door de ene kant op te gaan
en misschien pak je hem wel op,
misschien gebruik je hem door de tafelinstelling
te voltooien voor iemand anders die daar zal
dineren en dus zijn er zoveel manieren om te gebruiken
omdat gebruik
sociaal wordt uitgevoerd abductief
gecontextualiseerd enz
.  Fork
is waar dat gesprek plaatsvindt
en op onze veldsite of in het basiskamp
kunnen we ons de splitsingen en de
wegen voorstellen die Stephen
yeah en volgende in de in de
een manier vinden
om de auteurs te brengen als wie daar ook is, je
kent op een beetje een reis misschien
een van de splitsingen misschien gaat het naar de
rand van het meer en we moeten instappen
en een beetje nat worden,
dus hoe  kan wetenschappelijke
ontvoering of een soort van meer
wetenschappelijk begrensde
modellen regels onderbouwd door
experimenten en instrumentatie oke
wanneer
wanneer wordt dat verplaatst misschien
vanwege participatie misschien
vanwege transdisciplinariteit misschien vanwege
transformatieprocessen misschien
vanwege diepgaande verkenning
buiten het veld um  ik vraag me af of dit
iets is waar je over zou willen nadenken,
hoe kunnen we
een soort van duidelijke
reisopties geven, zodat ze
een beetje los kunnen komen zonder vast te komen te zitten
in een je weet wel in drijfzand of te
verdrinken in de in in het diepe water
rechts  dus we willen een beetje navigeren,
maar ik denk dat dit een
aantal van die um-aanwijzingen krijgt die ik denk aan
waar er een
soort
waze-afritten zijn, evenals  op-ramps dus
bedankt bedankt kerels
bedankt bedankt
dit was enorm ik waardeer echt
al je hulp
geweldige tijden tot ziens in de pop een
jij